it started on the subcommittee work
session for Senate Bill 44
and let's see
and this is the one
um
that makes some changes for uh mainly
the scope of practice for
the uh
m l Dax
and
you know representative groda has an
amendment if you want to just mention
what's in it
yes
um I'm sorry this is Senate Bill 44. yep
so incident Bill 44 originally
um criminal justice degrees were
accepted for this um well a specific
Criminal Justice Criminal Justice degree
that was being offered by
snow was in the
um was in the bill however they're no
longer offering that
class or that that series of courses so
that that is eliminated from the Builds
on page two
however they are going to enroll making
allow
um criminal justice degrees should these
specific courses be included in their
course of study so that's why the
amendment to house to Senate Bill 44 was
made and that's how the amendment is
written okay and uh director Courtney if
you could
come up I just have a question
I just want to verify that uh
well you can introduce yourself
certainly Lindsey Courtney executive
director oplc so my question is um since
there is a list
of degrees that meet the requirement is
there any problem adding something else
later in rulemaking or is that
I think as long as it is consistent with
the statutory definition then that that
would be okay I do know that they
currently already permit the what was
this new program under their existing
statutory framework so I don't think a
statutory change would be necessary
right but I mean this amendment would
remove
the criminal justice one and I'm
wondering if it's actually removed from
statute if you'd be able to allow it
under rulemaking that's my question oh
so my understanding was that Senate Bill
44 as introduced added the criminal
justice
um degree as a possible Pathway to
licensure it doesn't presently exist in
statute so by amending it to remove that
I think we would just be left with the
status quo okay but the question I mean
the question is if that criminal justice
program were offered again
for it to be accepted would it could
that be done in rule making or would it
require a statutory change I think it
could be done under rulemaking as the
board is presently already allowing that
it provided it meets the 60 hours
master's degree requirement okay thank
you
um any other comment on this
questions
okay
um in that case if somebody has emotion
yeah
Mr chair I'll move
the amendment
I've got in here somewhere but what's
the amendment number
one four five three h one four five six
three h
do we have a second
oh I'll second okay
okay so we're voting on adopting
Amendment one four five three h for
Senate bill 44. I'll just go around and
Order uh representative a bear yes
goalie yeah
yeah Bailey yes Rhoda yes and the chair
of votes yes one two three four five
okay
so we'll talk to the amendment and um
we have another motion
on
yes I'll move hard to pass as amended
okay
in a second
I can't okay
any discussion
take it no okay representative a bear
yes bully yes Bailey yes yes and the
triplets yes so five zero
we recommendations
otpa
easy I'm hoping and then
um
we'll go on to
Senate bill 149.
find it here
all right so this is the uh
relative nurse agencies that um
put some requirements on
what really sorts of things they can't
do
um at least from my standpoint the
biggest well there's two big ones one is
um
sort of bait and switch where they offer
somebody at a certain price at the last
minute they say oh somebody else is
offering more so they raise the price
and that
me I think I'd rather see it dealt with
by
looking at the contract to see if it's
in there and if it's uh if it's not
valid under the contract to get the AG
to handle it but I guess that's not
working so
um and the other one is the prohibition
of um
placing a nurse who is not
you know qualified to actually practice
in the state
due to license not you know licensing
problems or suspension so there's an
amendment to that
um
this amendment and I I believe I gave
you all the copies of the amendment so I
don't have the amendment number it's
right there on the table okay just a
moment sorry Walter that's okay
it should be 1463 H is that uh
yes okay cool
so if you could uh just describe what's
in the amendment
yes so in the amendment
um there was a
hanging prepositional clause for such
reason and then I didn't State a reason
so we scratched we eliminated that
clause and I believe it's on page two I
don't have the
the original bill it's on page two lines
uh eight and nine at the end of line
eight and uh
yeah nurse agencies may not shall not
commit the services of a single nurse or
licensed nursing assistant to more than
one Health Care Facility for the same
time period or shift and cancel a
commitment to a facility or compel that
facility to bid again for services
always prompt already promised it for
such reason but as you said yeah there's
nowhere up above does it say reason so
that makes no sense so that's I believe
that's the only change the amendment to
the bill that this amendment
um
that's that's the amendment to the front
to the bill so any questions or comments
on the amendment or the bill itself
actually
okay Glenn representative Bailey
yes thank you
um I have a problem on page two Roman
numeral three where you can't charge
extra under extraordinary circumstances
okay I don't care for that I believe
that's a violation of the law of supply
and demand which is a higher law than
this
yeah
um
yeah I can see that but
there's nothing in here that sets a
limit on
you know when what they could bid for
under providing a nurse in any
circumstance so there is I understand
that I mean the the
you know this may provide a little help
I don't think this is a significant
solution of the problem I think the real
solution is is to get more uh
nurses working
because I mean we've done some stuff for
her and there's you know wouldn't that
be achieved by paying a higher rate well
they this doesn't prevent them from
charging a higher rate it's just bumping
it up for certain circumstances
Mr chair if I may yes I think we heard
in testimony what was happening is after
contracts were made there were fees
added on above and beyond
um
due to instances such as coven once a
contract was made they were tacking on
an extra fifty dollar fee or sixty
dollar fee and if someone out there can
clarify whether I'm right or wrong on
that I think that's what I heard in
testimony and this is what that's trying
to prevent what's the contracts done to
say well we're in an emergency and by
the way the contract you sign we're
attacking on another such and such I see
that as similar to the problem of the
agree to provide a nurse at some price
and they say oh somebody's willing to
pay more almost literally at the last
minute and uh and bumping it up which
I suppose to you know depending on the
contracts written that may or may not be
a violation of contract but uh I think
we heard and maybe somebody here can
speak to it that they had contracts that
didn't mention increases due to the
Infectious Disease situation and then
they added the requirement at the last
minute I don't know if anybody
you want to come up and just introduce
yourself and
speak to that
foreign
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee Paula minihan from the
hospital Association I believe that is
accurate I recall that in the testimony
as well from some of the um individuals
that actually signed these contracts so
I think that's what we're trying to
address right I mean I don't have proof
of that but we certainly heard testimony
that that was going on and that's what
this is meant to
effect I mean if they but there's no
limit on me the charge they can charge
for providing a nurse so
which wouldn't make sense anyway I mean
because they're going to have to pay
what they're gonna have to pay to get
somebody any other questions or
discussions all right
would someone like to make a motion
I'll move the amendment 1463h
in a second I'll second
okay
no
all right any other any discussion on
this I do also want to make it
um Mrs minahan reminded me that we did
change the RSA reference oh that's right
excuse me for forgetting that
yeah it was uh which makes it a separate
registration
that's why I separate um RSA reference
was this is this is one that is not
being currently used so here we're going
to put it there right and um I think it
was under 326b which was the nursing one
and I mean they weren't I know they
weren't going to
when the nursing board wasn't going to
have anything to do with with this
anyway it's just the office so it didn't
make sense for it to be there okay thank
you
all right
um any other discussion
okay so we're going to vote on whether
or not to adopt Amendment 1463 h
to Senate bill 149.
um representative a bear yes goalie yes
Bailey
no and uh Groudon yes and the chair
votes yes so that's four to one
and do we have another motion
we'll have to pass as amended okay
any discussion probably not okay uh and
a second thank you my second okay
and we're voting on ought to pass
with Amendment 1463 age for Senate Bill
149 representative a bearer yes goalie
yes
Bailey no
okay and yes and the chair votes yes so
again that's four to one
and um
so I'm going to close the subcommittee
work session
um for these two bills
and we've got about 40 minutes I guess
and I'll get out of this chat
good morning everyone it is 10 o'clock
and I would like to open the public
hearing on SB 74 and welcome Grant boss
for Senator Carson
good morning thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Grant bossy from the New Hampshire
Senate introducing Senate Bill 74 on
behalf of Senator Sharon Carson the
Bill's Prime sponsor this bill is a
request of the Department of
administrative Services it makes several
small changes to clean up language in
the statutes to avoid confusion once
substantive change in section 16
authorizes the director of personnel to
review and approve salary adjustments
for employees who are hired at a higher
step than long-standing employees in
order to help with recruitment as you
know a long-standing problem that Das is
trying to address on several fronts SB
74 received unanimous support from the
Senate Edna and finance committees as
well as the full Senate I would defer
any questions to commissioner erlinghaus
and his staff Senator Carson thanks you
for your consideration in support of
Senate Bill 74. thank you thank you uh
will you take any questions if you have
questions for Senator Carson I can get
you an answer are there any questions
from the committee
sing then thank you very much thank you
the chair would like to call
Representative Carol McGuire uh who will
be presenting an amendment
1502h
and Carol McGuire representing Merrimack
27 which is Allenstown Dunbarton Epsom
and Hooksett
and this amendment to 74
is a request of the Department of
administrative Services also and it is
prime looks like a lot of little cleanup
and language adjustment you'll have to
ask them about the details but
none of it looks like it's making any
major changes to policy
and if you have technical questions I
will defer to the department if you have
other questions I'll be glad to answer
them
yes representative Schmidt
thank you very much Mr chairman
um and good morning representative
McGuire I I'm wondering whether the
proposed amendment has been discussed
with any members of the Senate as well
it has been discussed with the prime
sponsor Senator Carson who doesn't
object to it but didn't think she should
bring an amendment to the house
I I didn't hear the last part she didn't
think she should bring an amendment to
the house but she has no objections to
it thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you
Charlie arlinghaus from Department of
administrative services
boom so I filled out the card but I'm
not going to talk okay
um
uh I I'm Charlie arlinghaus and you'll
be happy to know I'm not going to talk
I'm the commissioner of administrative
services but with me are the two people
who know what's going on
good morning I'm Cassie Keane I'm the
Deputy Commissioner of Das and let's see
whether Charlie talks
Lori vertis so director for the division
of personnel thank you
um thank you to representative McGuire
first month for introducing our
Amendment
um this bill we requested Senator Carson
to sponsor in the Senate and we we had a
hearing with them and the question was
uh where these amendments discussed in
the Senate uh and I'll explain that
Lori rudis is our director of personnel
and she was hired back in 2018 2018 and
we actually in the recruitment process
talked about the need to update our
state Personnel system Charlie and I
were working together and working with
the agencies and there was a lot of
frustration about really an archaic
Personnel system that had been
established about 50 years ago and that
wasn't Nimble and didn't allow managers
to respond to whatever their business
needs were and we knew we had to
modernize the system and and make it
more flexible and and have it work for
agencies and managers
okay okay sorry
um so um much of this bill
is updating of language to support the
changes to the Personnel system that the
division of personnel is doing what are
they doing
um we when Lori came in we had a
Personnel system with more than 2 000
working titles for kinds of jobs across
state government we are reducing number
the numbers of titles and taking our
jobs in the state Personnel system and
mapping them back to National standards
for standard occupational codes and
um and having our system therefore be
more flexible to what is this position
what's the nature of it and what level
should it be so when we when we tie to
National standards there are there are
words that we have used in the past to
describe processes safer changing
positions that no longer will apply one
of those words that you'll see that
we're asking to be
um
removed from the law is reallocation
when we have a position let and I'll
I'll make it a stark contrast when we
have a position let's say it's a
secretary and we say I don't need a
secretary I need a manager we we do a
process called reclassification that is
going to be the new terminology and that
is an example of the kind of of
vocabulary changes that you'll see in
the bill why didn't we catch this stuff
earlier we're doing a lot of work on
many fronts all at the same time so
between the Senate hearing and today
we've continued to comb through the law
and and over here on my right is Matt
maver George Matt is an attorney he
worked in the AG's office for more than
a dozen years and he works with Lori to
comb through the laws the administrative
rules to to make sure that we're looking
forward with those and proposing changes
that support the modernization of the
system so I'm happy to walk through the
bill in the changes if you'd like or or
I whatever you would please
I I don't think we need to go probably
into quite that detail on it
um are you willing to take questions
sure representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman uh and good
morning to all of you from Das uh I'm
asking this question in my capacity as a
member of the jcec uh which commissioner
arlinghaus is the one of the uh primary
operators here and uh and uh also on our
committee is the new chair of the JCC
representative leckis and so I'm
wondering uh the the the terminology
changes that you're that you're talking
about uh are they also in the in the
neighborhood of or in the category of
classification changes because that's
what uh jcec is a task with uh I'm
wondering if you could speak to that
issue sure the the jcec the joint
committee and employee classification is
um is functionally the governing body of
the unclassified system uh unclassified
employees are typically appointed
employees with three of us all happen to
be unclassified
um and they they tend to be
Commissioners and and the like
um
this is all about the classified system
which is the 11
um
regular normal typical state employees
as opposed to the 346 or 48 or whatever
it is now
um class unclassified employees so none
of the none of it is relevant in that
system and and the you know the word
structures are different the you know
the the big difference is that that
um you know the changes that were made
73 years ago if we're counting
um to the classified system back in my
youth in your youth yes in uh in 1950
um is uh they govern everybody and
there's a lot of technical language I
mean a lot of what's going on you know
increases in salary because becomes
changes in compensation and that kind of
thing year after year people just don't
bother you know the the you know we do
what we do and the law says something
close to what we do and we just let it
go and it because it doesn't stop us
from doing it but this is about making
you know the law uses terms that we
actually use and so you don't read the
statue and go well what they mean is
like it says reallocation but it's just
everything that we call a
reclassification oh okay and this makes
all those kind of changes but it doesn't
affect the jcec processor language at
all thank you
yes representative Lucas
um thank you I'm taking a look at um the
amendment
and trying to see what it changes so the
amendment that affects section six as
far as I've gotten as far as I can tell
let me know if I'm missing something all
it does is remove three words at the end
or the board
um the rest of it just looking through
it it seems identical so it is it does
it do anything else
yes the the I mean frankly the
uh the amount if you think of the
amendment as as our lawyer having looked
at the draft that came out and looked at
oh wait they that word's missing and
that because in in anytime you draft
something occasionally you know because
things are added and subtracted somebody
goes oh wait wait wait wait wait we
forgot to
no people left out the and or the word
assigning for example is added so it's
all it's very legalistic I guess
follow-up if I may follow up yeah my
specific question is on that
um the part that affects section six
isn't changing anything other than the
three words at the end removing them
from section six
not in section six no okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Billy
thank you Mr chair
I just have a question as to why
um
when we are looking to provide these
bonuses of doing whatever we're doing
why we are no longer involving um for
spending money involving the fiscal
committee
um
I think that what you're what your might
be referencing in is it in the general
Bill where we're um where you're gonna
where you see the uh redaction of the
Recruitment and Retention bonuses yes on
page one starting in line 12. I can I
can a committee to
um to empower the division of personnel
to establish a program to award
um Recruitment and Retention bonuses and
um that bill got amended in the Senate
and it required those those changes in
the Senate required approval of the
fiscal Committee of policies and and
payment amounts and that the Senate put
in a sunset provision into that
um the their amendment of that bill and
um since that time we did we did
establish a recruitment
bonus program and a retention bonus
program funded by arpa funds approved by
fiscal policies approved by fiscal but
that law sunsets and so
pardon June 30th June 30th at at the end
of this biennium so um that's why you
see that redaction in their bill
for the question below
when I go to and let me find it I had it
here in front of me a minute ago
uh we'll go to page six
uh line starting on line 13 the salary
adjustment
the bill itself left your money yes
Page Six
line 14.
the director of personnel has approved
beginning compensation at a step higher
than the minimum step
and then it goes on to say that
they may increase
for
the salary for others in the similar
positions
if it affects
recruitment and retention
now we've
we're here in her to build not too long
ago with nursing staffing agencies and
the problem they were having when they
were recruiting and hiring nurses from
travel agencies at higher pay and there
was a little bit of animosity of people
making more and I guess my question is
why wouldn't you
if you're going to hire someone at a
higher pay grade doing the same work
then
automatically move the rest of those
Folks up doing the same work if you want
to retain them
you um it's actually what the bill is is
trying to address is there are
situations where that happens and and if
you think about it
um in a
I'm going to give us an example in in a
division you you hire somebody uh
um you hire somebody for one particular
job and they have the similar title and
it happens to be you know labor grade
let's just say 25 and they're a step
four somebody else comes in and and
based on on where they were where they
were coming from their level of
experience you hire them uh occasionally
at maybe a step eight
um once in a while that happens as a
one-off you know somebody's getting
hired right out of college into a job
somebody else is getting hired who's
been working for 20 years and and they
they come in because of where they their
life experience and on a in a one-off
case that can happen a lot and and
everybody doesn't necessarily get
adjusted the the situation where it's
mostly problematic is when
um
uh the job market changes and I'm going
to use I'm going to use for example our
ground screw right the job market
changes there's no chance we can hire
anybody at step one there's just you
know you can you can do much better than
that at Dunkin Donuts and so what what
happens is you're hiring people at that
point at step five everybody who comes
in and gets hired at step five you've
got you've got a handful of people who
were at step three and and aren't in the
way the normal system works necessarily
adjust it the idea is to get some
authority to do that to address the
issue you're talking about why why would
we say to the guy who's at step three
look it's not that you don't have the
experience it's not that it's not that
you know he's been doing this for 40
years and you're new
um he just happened to get hired at a
different time and the somebody could
make that make that adjustment and this
grants that Authority today there's no
authority to do that they would have to
frankly the the quote unquote work
around as they would quit
and then you would rehire them and
that's a little cheesy and so this is to
give the the state an opportunity to do
something that's not cheesy if that
makes sense
any other questions
I'm seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony
and you didn't speak admirably
thank you
uh that is the last pink card I have on
SB 74 was there anybody else in the room
who wanted to speak on this bill
saying none I will close the public
hearing on SB 74
and we will reconvene in 25 minutes
oh
sure
I'll let you do that
since we do have a quorum
and
I'd like to mention that today is
Wednesday
obviously and the deadline for committee
reports to be in the calendar for the
session next week is today
so
we're going to
this afternoon in our executive session
deal first with any bill that has a
committee report already written so I
will rely on you to whip up a few over
lunch
and we'll try to get as many as possible
into the calendar just to make it easier
on all of us
and
and that case
I'll I suggest we have an executive
session on this bill Senate bill 74.
and I will move ought to pass with
Amendment
and bring out Amendment 1502 H is there
there's a second thank you
representative Gould
um I don't want to say anything you wish
to speak to your motion there your
second
thank you okay
representative a bear
oh I have a question Madam chair and I'm
not sure who it goes to but I guess it's
just a discussion item
so one thing that really goes against my
spirit is when we have funds that res
that we receive through grants and then
it's sunsets that's what I just heard
and maybe I didn't hear that correctly
that
it's a fiscal note there's no money on
it and then we would
those funds expire and then what happens
is that tax paying money that has to now
go to that I'm I'm just unsure thank you
I and representative oh
I'll give my understanding of this and
then correct me if I'm wrong because I'm
not certain I'm right and that is I
think the uh the arpa funds are being
used as I understand it for
um
you know the hiring bonuses to get more
people in
but that that program sunsets and I
wasn't sure whether it was
June 30th this year said at the end of
the biennium which would be next year if
that's correct but in any case it
sunsets as well and then the grant money
presumably sunsets and so we're not
sending my understanding is we're not
setting ourselves up for an ongoing
expense when the grant money goes away
is that your understanding my
understanding is that the bonuses are
paid when the people are hired and if we
do it right there will not be any money
left over to turn back to the federal
government
is that correct commissioner
yes although it's possible that there
will be money turned over the federal
government because it but there's
there's no obligations of the state
there's not an ongoing obligation of any
sort so programs are all expiring when
is it actually expiring it's a June 30th
of this year this year okay thank you
thank thank you thank you for your for
the uh and information representative
does that answer your question yes okay
good any other questions or comments
issues I have a question so uh your
Amendment as representative leckis was
at least alluding to uh does
um
basically make
uh there are a number of changes that
are made in the in at Senate bill 74.
and your Amendment picks all those
changes up
and and and and repeats the impeach them
and incorporates them and so forth and
uh so the the only question I have is
has this been carefully vetted with
regard to just the secretarial aspect if
you will because otherwise there's a lot
of you know you keep looking this way
and you're shifting back and forth net
effect is nothing to some degree
different than is already in the bill
but if it hasn't been carefully vetted
then it could be that we're
we're going to have to pick it all up
again in the Senate because
they haven't done this stuff
and
and Miss Keane have
good
and if you find it at first glance at
first glance I was seeing the same
things that representative like has
pointed out it's the same thing and
there are very few additional changes in
your Amendment but the bottom line is
there those are there and if it's if
they've carefully vetted it it's on you
no
and since they're the ones that are
going to have to follow these
I'm sure they take that
thank you madam chair
um I would just make the comment that as
the commissioner stated that the current
steps for certain positions are not
adequate to attract employees or retain
employees that perhaps you should
consider increasing steps for certain
positions
going forward
okay thank you I'm sure they will take
that to heart
and to budget
representative
um this is more of a follow-on question
so it if this ends in June this bill
says it would pass after 60 days would
that
then
why would we be passing it I didn't
understand
no
the grant the arpa grants end in 60 days
which means that they would not be able
to pay bonus recruitment bonuses from
those grants
after the end of June but the but
you are allowed to do so under current
law correct
I mean clearly as they have been paying
recruitment bonuses
the the bonus part so the the
the Bill's not in it's only a little
tiny piece of the bill that it's the the
arpa funded retention and recruitment
things and and those are all those are
all going away but the rest of the bill
is not
and that's so that's the the rest of the
bill takes effect in 60 days the arpa
thing just goes away
okay representative blackis yeah I mean
again if I understand the uh we we
passed a uh a bill last time letting
them do this to have the arpa thing and
that the change related the arpa thing
as I understand is if you look on page
one
um you know from 13 to page two
eight it's just deleting that stuff so
the money's going away and the authority
to do it is going to
win
okay
representative thank you madam chair
um thank you commissioner is is there a
specific time limit that the arpa funds
have to be used by and have they all
been
accounted for
I I think the bonus programs are
essentially done
is any does anyone have a tail
yeah
no so they're all they're all they were
one-time events and and they've all
expired at this point
okay follow-up follow-up and did were we
able to use all of those funding
according to the rules the the funding
that was allocated by fiscal from the
arpa funds is
um I I don't want to say all because all
implies 100 most
um we you know there's a there's a
budget we kind of knew how many
positions were covered by the
um the retention incentives Etc and uh
and we had a decent estimate of how many
people would get hired
um and it and it worked out so we were
we were pretty close but there's someone
there's some left over that goes back to
arpa and and then don't ask me what they
do because I have in the focus
spend it foolishly no doubt
representative Bailey
thank you madam chair
um I guess it's that same section that's
being deleted
the Roman numeral six developing a
program for the recruitment selection
placement and retention of specified
applicants in the state service and then
everything after it is deleted
so I'm kind of wondering why is that
even there then unless you need this
bolts on a placeholder or
all of the stuff you should have a
program for Recruitment and Retention
but they won't have the specific
arpa-funded bonus program but they
should have a plan for how they're going
to I just wondered if we needed another
line of strikeouts but no there needs to
be something that would certainly hope
they have a program for recruiting
thank you everybody does I mean
if you run a agency
a hot dog stand or anything you have a
plan for Recruitment and Retention and
you know we have a we have a unit that
helps with recruitment just the
statutory Authority here is not
necessary for that operational
thing thank you okay other questions
comments
all right in that case the motion is to
adopt yes
who's that
one second
all right so representative sorry
no I think I moved my
excuse me that's okay and it just
startled me the Deputy Commissioner
seems to be on the verge of speaking
almost without permission
you can't have that but she she clearly
wants to say something and I
say all I was gonna say when back to the
Recruitment and Retention program is
um the strikeouts about the Recruitment
and Retention program reflect
um Senate Bill 226 from last session
that authorized the the program that
again in the law Sunset it so the
strikeouts reflect the law that
sunsetted and the language that remains
that was the question
um is the the language that has been in
the statute for ever
okay thank you
any other comments
all right then the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1502 H to Senate Bill 74 and
the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nostazo oh he's
absent excuse me
representative true
yay
representative Dolan yes representative
abar yes representative Gerhard yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative Horrigan
yes representative grassy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Schmidt I mean Smith
Smith yes and the chair yes 18-0 the
amendment passes all right the amendment
is adopted and I move ought to pass with
Amendment on Senate bill 74.
all right I'll second thank you
have anything to say
Ricky Simon do you have a comment uh no
second
and you moved you made in the motion you
made the first time I made the motion
okay yes thank you and the uh
questions comments or discussion
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative true
yay representative Dolan yes
representative abar yes representative
gerhardt yes the clerk votes yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes representative Horrigan yes
representative Grassi yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes
18 to zero the OTP passes all right
thank you the is any objection to
consent
I don't think it spends any money so I
think we're okay
thank you representative Schmidt for
that load of confidence okay I would
like to work to welcome representative
grassy who will be on this committee
permanently in place of Representative
Wilhelm so I hope we'll be have his
attends more often and we have 15
minutes breaks before the next spill
which will give me time to write my
committee report
foreign
all right
what's the difference and
Percival kill who's in several pages of
testimony with five addictions to the
bill
here
foreign
yes
suddenly attorneys Bill standings
what's going on just utterly ridiculous
that's a pain in the neck
lace 15 seconds
judge
that's on the five
January 16th
foreign
that's it
yes
it's a nice rap
battles that's
nice
please
very well how are things things are
welcome yeah
uh
um
yeah
no it's um
if it's not saving the state money
foreign
somehow
exceptions
okay
um
nuance
okay
that's okay
um
okay
good I see you're on 105 yes
how do we know who belongs
well it strikes the person with
identifiable information
after
this time
and I talked to Carol so it started very
safe Carol it's uh
so Carol has a proposed amendment
she will
explain what the heck the sentence
right here and I don't know why yeah
well actually I went and I found you
know they they have Clerks of these paid
staff to take notes and that's available
and I went and I realized and it didn't
really explain there was some discussion
but nothing well that explained why
somebody wrote this enough people
Etc
I mean I've got I was looking at this
last night
period I mean I've got the bill once
interviews
um I was on that study participated by
4.4 with uh Senator Rosenwald and Jess
Edwards
please
it doesn't cost
well some the criminal panels don't
apply
only the information on your mother's
worksheets for the person
so not apply to the product numbers
information for the mother statistical
so no criminal countries I mean you
don't have it yeah
foreign
what parts
right
state
thank you
okay so that's the deal
um yeah I mean yeah
foreign
um
I mean your bill is introduced to a very
simple story
and yeah the Secretary of State came to
Carol and said uh this passes
foreign
and the idea was
we right now are required to give
Motorcity
and the original Bill Limited
[Music]
it was like
of course
um
yes please
I thought I had I thought I had a
question
over there oh okay
and I just sent you the amendment for
147 up to committee services
already they should be there
oh yeah
is he getting enough for everybody are
there enough Tony or do you want me to
go get copies oh yeah okay
don't
stop
welcome back I'm opening the hearing on
Senate bill 108.
and I call uh grand flossie for Senator
Carson
thank you madam chair members of the
Edna committee I'm Grant bossy from the
New Hampshire Senate introducing Senate
Bill 108 on behalf of Senator Sharon
Carson the Bill's Prime sponsor as you
well know New Hampshire's public
defender program has a recruitment and
retention problem something that most
businesses and government agencies are
currently facing a recent survey of
public defenders found that high case
loads and low salary were the two
biggest challenges but Access to Health
Care ranked third SB 108 would allow
public defenders to opt in to the State
Health Plan providing both better
coverage at lower cost and since this is
a 100 percent General funded program
lower cost would mean savings to
taxpayers the Senate Amendment changed
the effective date from 60 days after
passage to a pond passage this is order
in order to align with their current
insurance contract which expires June
30th SB 108 received unanimous support
from the Senate Edna and finance
committees as well as the full Senate
it's an important tool to help fill
vacancies in our public defender program
lower case loads and cut into the
backlog of 650 cases now pending Senator
Carson thanks you for your consideration
and ask for your support of Senate Bill
108 thank you
thank you are there
um
I you said that this was General funded
which seems to imply it's funded from
the general fund I I'm suspecting that's
not the case would you like to
indicate where the money comes from uh I
was told that this was a general fund
appropriation I could be wrong on that
after there'll be people back here to
clarify that
all right that would be good
could you restate with the number one
and number two reason for
leaving yeah I don't have the survey
results uh in front of me but they were
one high case loads and two uh salary
and then third was health care benefits
is representative gold so the hope is
that um
that uh
by offering this additional benefit
you'll be able to recruit and hire more
public defenders which will lower
caseloads and attack item number one
that is the hope I don't think Senator
Carson believes that would solve the
problem completely but it's another tool
at the margins to get people into the
public defender program instead of going
to another practice
thank you and thank you madam chair okay
any other questions
Sarah Rothman
foreign
just turned your mic off
there you go I apologize good morning my
name is Sarah Rothman I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire public
defender I've been at the public
defender uh for 15 years
um as you likely know
um there are both federal and state
constitutional requirements for the
state to provide legal representation to
defendants who cannot afford an attorney
we fulfill that role in New Hampshire so
we contract with the state we contract
through the judicial Council to provide
representation to every Indigent
defendant in our court system we
represent
well north of 80 percent of all criminal
defendants in New Hampshire in New
Hampshire an additional in addition to
the Constitutional requirements
requiring that we exist there's actually
also a statute in New Hampshire that
requires the state of New Hampshire to
contract with a firm to provide this
representation to Indigent defendants we
have been we were founded in 1972 so we
we've been in existence for 50 years and
we've contracted with the state since
1985. we've been the provider of these
services to the citizens of New
Hampshire
we're here today asking to you to
approve this legislation because it will
benefit all stakeholders in the criminal
justice system
all stakeholders that includes judges
Court staff City and County Prosecutors
victims of crime and defendants are
impacted by retention problems at the
New Hampshire Public Defender
when nhpd cannot retain its staff it
results in delays and logistical
problems for everyone involved in the
system
When we struggle due to staff attrition
it makes it more difficult for everyone
in the system to do their job
so we aren't just asking you to help
improve the lives of our employees we're
asking you to help the criminal justice
system in New Hampshire to function
since fiscal year 2021 alone
140 employees have left the New
Hampshire Public Defender
52 employees left in fiscal year 2022.
that's an average of one employee every
single week
so far in the fiscal year 2023 we've
lost 43 employees and 22 of those have
been attorneys
every time we lose a staff member we
have to devote substantial resources to
recruiting interviewing and most
importantly training new staff members
when we lose attorneys and when we lose
investigators their caseloads must be
transferred to already overburdened
colleagues
and this then fuels more attrition
we need to break this cycle and this
legislation will help us to do that
why has attrition spiked at nhpd over
the last four years
it's because the benefits that draw that
used to draw people to the public
defender and key people at the public
defender have eroded over time
our health insurance has become more
expensive and for our employees and the
quality of the benefits has decreased
the State Health Plan work will keep
people at the New Hampshire Public
Defender
we are competing in a historically hot
job market with private sector and with
neighboring public defenders
organizations that offer better pay and
benefits
we will continue to struggle with
attrition if our staff can leave for a
public defender program in a nearby
state that has a more attractive
benefits package to offer
I want to tell you that as the executive
director of the public defender I am
incredibly confident that this
legislation the ability to join the
State Health Plan will help retain our
staff it will keep people I hear that
from people regularly
that yes case laws are an issue I know
that was discussed earlier caseloads are
an issue but again as was pointed out if
we're able to retain and recruit staff
that will help with caseloads but what
we hear uh quite as frequently is that I
could deal with the with the caseload I
understand that you know public defender
has high case loads but if I had better
benefits particularly if you know going
to the doctor was not sort of a
frightening event where I could be stuck
with a large Bill where having a child
is not so difficult to to do while
you're working at the public defender we
hear that over and over again that
benefits will retain our staff and help
us recruit our staff
so our employees have been clear Health
Care is a priority for them the ability
to join the State Health Plan would be a
game changer for the public defender it
will draw people to nhpd and will keep
people here
and again this is a benefit not just for
our employees and not just for the
clients that we represent it's a benefit
for the entire criminal justice system
if nhpd can better retain its staff all
stakeholders will benefit
thank you again for your time and for
considering this legislation
thank you are there questions
representative true
thank you madam Jeff thank you for
taking my question on on page on on line
six of the bill page one
the public defender program will
reimburse the state for the premiums
where do you get the money from sure
to reimburse the state sure and so that
ties into the earlier question we are
funded through the general fund we are
100 funded through the general fund and
so we it's kind of an interesting kind
of just cycle so we get funding through
the state and then we pay the state for
the health insurance through our budget
so you're laundering funds from the gym
general fund to the employee benefits
fund
essentially I see okay
representative true you have a follow-up
thank you madam chair
um and on the last line uh on the last
two lines public defender program opts
in if the public defender opts in it
should be for two years correct it
sounds like you're not holding people
even for two years
so
um I mean certainly yes we're dealing
with attrition for sure I mean certainly
there's been employees who've been here
for we have some I think our longest
serving employee has been here for 36
years so we have plenty of staff that
have been here for a long time but
um I think the two years is just that
and I frankly I think if we are able to
join the state health insurance I don't
think that we would ever leave the state
health insurance
um it's just so that we don't sort of
Burden the state with getting on the
plan and then choosing next year to get
off the plan and then going back on the
plan I think that they wanted some
guarantee that if they're going to do
the administrative work to get us on the
plan that it will be for at least two
years but like I said I I don't Envision
um you know us ever going back to
Private health insurance if we're able
to join the state plan thank you
representative lackas thank you um so I
I looked at a fiscal note and I
understand why you know it's difficult
or impossible to come up with a precise
uh answer because there's you know
variables you know size that who opts in
their characteristics and all that
however
I have a problem voting for something
where there's just no clue I mean there
should at least be possible to have a
range
of possible cost to this thing and I
can't see how to vote for it without at
least some idea
so somebody could provide that I don't
know if that's you or someone else it
would be helpful I so I can I can't give
you the range right now I can certainly
follow up but I can speak to that issue
a little bit as well um but we can
follow up with a range
um what I can tell you is um the health
care costs will certainly be cheaper for
the employee and it will be cheaper for
the New Hampshire public defender the
only issue that could cause cost to
increase is that we do expect because
this is such an attractive benefit that
people who are currently not receiving
health insurance through the public
defender so either through their they
get it through their spouse or through
some other source might join our plan
because
um because it's a better plan but I I
can also tell you um you know one of the
reasons why it's hard to pin down a
number is because currently With Private
health insurance not only is nhpd
covering premiums we're also covering a
percentage of claims and so that we will
no longer have to do that under the
state health insurance plan so the
increase in cost that we anticipate
potentially based on increased
utilization of our health plan will be
offset I don't think completely but will
be offset by the idea that we are no
longer going to have to be paying a
percentage of claims follow-up okay
um
yeah it wasn't clear to me how things
currently work who's paying for the
health care and how this changes that so
it sounds from what you just said that
um
that nhpd is already paying for at least
some portion of their health care how
does it work now and how would that
change sure so as we're funded through
the general fund we are literally just
given a budget and then we have to use
that budget to pay all of our expenses
and so we use our budget to pay for
health care and we contract right now
it's through Cigna and through Cigna
obviously we have premium costs we
actually nhpd covers I think it's around
92 percent of the premium costs the
employee pays eight percent of the
premium cost and then the employee pays
a percentage of the claims and we pay a
percentage of the claims nhpd plays a
percentage of the claims but all of this
because we're from the general fund one
way or the other it's it's all paid
through through State funds um it's just
you know it's it's a line item in our
budget
um that that we use our funds to cover
follow-up
um
so
I mean they're getting health insurance
and HPD is paying for it sounds like
probably for the bulk of it I don't know
what percentage overall so how does that
how does the the cost and who pays what
part of it change If This Were to sure
so
um the premium costs are just lower
under the state so both to nhpd and to
the employee so the cost for say a
family plan is cheaper under both for
nhpd and for the employee so the health
care costs are actually lower for nhpd
under the state plan it's just the idea
that because it's an attractive benefit
we might see increased utilization
um but so we we currently pay like I
said the premium and then a percentage
of claims moving forward we're just
going to be paying premiums and another
reason why it's hard to pin down a
number is because you know there's if
we're able to join the plan then there's
a period where you know we can negotiate
premiums and so we don't quite know
exactly what the premiums are going to
be as well
um perhaps
if you could mention little details like
how many employees you have sure
yes so we have I think the count today
is
um it's I think 251 or 252 employees
okay thank you representative Lancaster
follow-up okay
um
so from what you're saying
the savings both
um
to the department which might be offset
by more people you know being involved
in the plan and to the employees is is
because as I understand it the premiums
are going to be less and you don't you
and the employee don't have to pay a
portion of the claims is I mean is it
going to go down because you're joining
the other plan It's a larger group and
therefore they get better rates or
um I think that's possible I I'm not
sure what you're saying then is is
self-insured they pay the state pays the
claims that's correct okay thank you
okay I have a a question online
um
eight and nine it says the public
defender shall be permitted is that your
organization or is it each individual
it's our organization yes
yes we are not we're not going to engage
in yes we we will either be able to join
the state plan or we will have to stay
with private insurance
okay thank you that wasn't entirely
clear okay
and all right
all right like and I'm I'm kind of
surprised that the premium is being
lower unless you're a very high risk
because
I was on the state plan as a legislator
for a few years and it was
although it covered a great deal it was
also a very pricey plan
and has that actually has actually
changed I mean comparatively to what
we're able to get in the private Market
it is considerably cheaper all right
thank you that's interesting we we are
relatively small organization so our
bargaining power
um you know we're only about 250
employees and so when we go out and get
a private contract we don't have a great
deal of bargaining power because we are
a small organization representative and
then Matt Gould
so I think that correct me if I'm wrong
the way I'm understanding this
that this bill would allow your your
group to join the
State Health state employee health plan
and that it would reduce the cost of the
overall
health care for your employees because
you wouldn't be paying the premium
premium and you'd be paying a lower rate
correct I mean the the employee will
still pay a percentage of the premium
yes and then if
and then if you choose to
opt into this plan
your employees could choose to opt in
themselves right they're not necessarily
are they will they be required to join
the health plan
so or they can go out in the market and
get their own correct I mean we're we're
not going to offer both the state plan
and a private option we're only going to
offer the one option but correct they
could either get insurance through us or
through their spouse or you know on
their own if I guess if they wanted to
right okay thank you and I believe if
I'm not correct if I'm not mistake
follow up excuse me I just want to that
the plan that the state employee plan
that state employees are on is less
expensive than the ones that we are
offered as state
they are less expensive than what the
public defender program is able to buy
is a small group Market all right thank
you
okay represent bold
well I would just add on to that what I
uh to what representative Grody just
said Madam chair
um what I had heard was that as a rep I
can buy into the plan but I don't get
the state employee rate
that I have to pay the full right I
don't get some of the reimbursement
subsidies and so they will be getting
that
um lower rate of the state employee that
we don't get as Representatives that may
be why you noticed a difference
that
that that is correct and I can also
point out um you know we are would not
be the only non-governmental agency
um on the state on the state plan
um they have a they have
um a group called The statutorily
authorized groups said they call us a
sag
um so yes there are other organizations
um that are on the state plan who are
not state employees
thank you and I think that may be the
difference
legislators as a representative Horrigan
thank you very much yes we
when I was um
yes I I never paid into the state
employee plan I when the Affordable Care
Act came in I found that was a better
option but that's uh which is probably
not
an option for your for employees and now
I want Medicare and you miss you to
um signal plan some of my questions
first of all how was your overall cost
of Labor like going up because there's
you're trading off probably better
health insurance plan for the salary and
then also what do you
what are you planning to offer your
employees should or is that still
subject negotiation for uh if you should
be
if this bill should pass and the the
executives of the plan and all that so
like what what will their co-p be and
what would you be paying so that is to
be determined
um but I think from what I've looked at
it's it's a significant savings to both
staff and as I've said and to nhpd the
premium for us is cheaper as well
um but was there another question I can
answer I I apologize
they don't have the I guess just just
the way the ACA is uh structured they
don't have the option of buying an ACA
plan instead of yours or do they they do
not have the option to buy subsidized
ACA plants which is a big difference
yes representative Smith
if I'm reading this correctly uh
apparently there's like 245 employees
right now in your agency and 201 are on
the plan already so you're talking 40
some people give or take
that's that's the potential um and again
we I don't think we expect every single
one of those um you know some some
people are married to people who already
have state health insurance so we may be
just talking 20 people correct something
like that correct okay yes
representative Simon thank you madam
chair just a quick clarification 252 is
fully stopped or what you have on staff
at the moment that's what we have on
snap at the moment what would fully
stuff look like
you know I
higher when we live when we lose people
so we are actually right now not bad I
mean I think we would like to add
um you know every every fall we get a
new group we're having 19 new lawyers
that are starting in the fall but we do
expect attrition between now and then
um so usually you know it kind of plays
out around we like to be around between
250 and 260 employees thank you other
questions
right thank you very much thank you
Gregory Erskine
it's the microphone on yes yes I am my
name is Gregory close to it you have to
be close to the microphone
my name is Greg Erskine I am a
stay-at-home father of four and resident
of Manchester I'd like to thank this
house committee for allowing me time to
speak
a couple of months ago my wife Heather
and I moved here from Kentucky where we
lived for the last eight years we had
moved there because my wife was hired by
the Louisville Office of the public
defender and we've just moved to
Manchester because she was hired by the
New Hampshire public defender so SB 108
is a bill that would impact our family
greatly
one of the reasons that we decided to
uproot our lives and move to New
Hampshire was because New Hampshire's
office seemed more efficiently run than
Louisville's was so this bill which is
likely to give the public defenders A
Better Health Plan is exactly the kind
of lure that would bring in the best and
brightest from all over the country but
the other reason that we wanted to move
to New Hampshire is that it is my home I
was born in Concord Hospital I was
raised in Manchester I was educated in
Manchester's Public Schools my parents
were likewise lifelong residents of
Manchester as were my four grandparents
and I am Overjoyed to be back in my
beloved home state and I am happy that
my wife's work can serve the state that
I love so deeply and I feel
extraordinarily blessed to be able to
raise our kids here
we do our best to keep our kids healthy
with regular checkups and good food and
running around in fresh air but one
can't always prepare for every
eventuality
last summer our five-year-olds
complained that her back was sore we
asked the doctor about it she said it
was likely nothing major just keep an
eye on it and the problem continued to
worsen eventually X-rays showed severe
damage to her lower spine
no one knew why the spinal surgeon who
examined her said he'd never seen
anything like this
so the doctors ran tests scans biopsies
I spent many nights with my little
kindergartner in the hospital
eventually it was determined that it was
a bacterial infection which could be
treated with antibiotics although the
damage to her spine remains
this experience brought home to me that
there are some severe illnesses that you
can't prevent or prepare for they befall
us and we can only hope that there are
medical professionals that can help and
that your insurance out of pocket
maximum doesn't ruin a person
financially
if SB 108 passes the switch from nhpd's
current Insurance to the state Employee
Program could save a family like ours
thousands of dollars in the event of an
unforeseen medical emergency such as the
one that we experienced
we moved here because my wife's job
allows her to serve the most vulnerable
citizens of New Hampshire
SB 108 is legislation that will help
working families who are here to make
New Hampshire a better place for
everyone
thank you so much for your time
thank you for your testimony and welcome
to New Hampshire thank you are there any
questions
okay
yes thank you representative Schmidt for
that clarification I don't see any
questions so thank you thank you
alien forciniti
good morning
and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak today
um my name is Eliana forciniti I've been
with the New Hampshire Public Defenders
for uh 11 years now as a senior staff
attorney I have a mainly felony focused
caseload though I've represented
individuals from everything from
juvenile cases to murder
along with that case stud on top of it I
also for the past three years have been
a member of the trial skills team now
recently I was promoted and now I'm the
trial skills team leader as a member and
now leader of trial skills that means I
am the individual responsible for
leading trainings for our incoming class
so as
um Sarah spoke about each year we have
an incoming class and I'm one of the
people that's responsible for training
them on how to be a trial lawyer
uh my husband uh actually also works for
the New Hampshire Public Defenders as a
staff attorney he has been with the
program for nine years
uh I also have permission to speak on
behalf of two other individuals who
could not be here uh Sarah and Cherry
who has been an investigator with the
program for 15 years now uh and Kara
samard who was with the program for nine
years before she left in December due in
part to our health care plan both of
those individuals did submit written
testimony and I do hope that you have
the opportunity to read that testimony
because I will reference it but I cannot
speak as eloquently as they can about
their own experiences
um the one well one of the things that
the three of us have in common is that
we all three had children while employed
at nhpd
for me that happened in December of 2021
when we welcomed my daughter a catalea
Eva
um I've always known that we've had a
high deductible when I first started it
was much better everything was covered
we didn't pay as much I didn't use it uh
and so uh when I had my daughter was
really the first time I had to use our
health insurance
um and as Fortune would have it because
of the pregnancy the way you know the
time frame of the pregnancy I got to use
it twice because I was I spanned to plan
years so I paid a thousand dollars for a
relatively easy pregnancy and then
because I did have an emergency
C-section I paid
um
I maxed out our deductible and our
out-of-pocket Max and had to pay five
thousand dollars for that on top of that
when I got home from the hospital
um you know you're in the hospital the
doctors are telling you your baby needs
this you're of course saying yes of
course it's in network hospitals in
Portsmouth
um and lo and behold Apparently one of
those providers was at a network and so
Cigna was refusing to cover it and so on
top of being home having to deal with
postpartum and a new baby I also had to
be fighting with the health insurance
who were trying to not uh pay for
something that they should
you know this is my experience
um and and why I why I think it's
important to share and what I think is
important for for all of you to to know
um
is that
you know well in terms of my Five-Year
Plan I certainly want to have another
child
um I need to think about whether it
makes sense for me to knowingly have to
pay another five thousand dollars to
have another child to stay at a job that
I that I love I mean even now you know I
and I hate to admit this but when my
daughter comes home from daycare and she
has a cold you know I need to think to
myself is is it really worthwhile to go
to the doctor
um with our really high uh cost you know
it's a hundred to two hundred dollars
each time I have to take her to the
hospital or to the doctor not the
hospital but
um and so it's something I I have to
think about and I hate
that I have to think about it and when
you look at the stability of the program
what we really need in terms of
retaining lawyers is we really need
lawyers in the three to five five to
eight year range the this is the core of
the program the reason for that is
because at that point they have a full
case load they don't need as much
supervision as they needed before and
they're starting to Mentor new lawyers
um either formally through our mentoring
program or informally as just you know
sometimes a new lawyer doesn't want to
ask someone with 11 years experience a
question they feel more comfortable
going to someone with three years
um and so it's really important to have
those lawyers in the office and when we
don't we send out these new lawyers we
get a new shiny you know new class I I
love interacting with them they are so
excited to start working at the program
and it's a great program but we send
them to these to their offices and they
don't have the support that they need
because there aren't these more
experienced lawyers there and they're
getting cases that they can they just
cannot handle and that they wouldn't be
getting if we had those lawyers in the
three to five five to eight year range
and so they leave as well
these would be people that we wouldn't
be losing if we could retain the lawyers
and the three to five five to eight year
range these same lawyers who are
probably thinking about having a family
and they're thinking about whether it's
worthwhile to spend five thousand
dollars to have at least to have
um a family
the other thing that all three of us
have in common is how hard our jobs are
our hearts are our jobs are really
really hard not just the secondary PTSD
um that Sarah talks very eloquently
about and so does Cara but also just the
emotional toll of our cases
when I go to trial sometimes I'll wear a
fitness watch and my fitness watch will
tell me that I have run a marathon
because my heart is racing my anxiety
I'm not sleeping I'm not eating
and that's what's required because I
have to care about my clients in order
to do the job that I
am hired to do and that I love doing but
that's really hard to do and it's really
hard to do when I don't have access to
mental health care I don't see a
therapist my husband does not go to
therapy
because again if I'm making a decision
of taking my daughter to the doctor
because it would cost a hundred dollars
or two hundred dollars
I'm not going to make the decision to go
to therapy when it would cost 60 to 100
for me to attend a session
and you see that in all the lawyers and
a lot of the lawyers who have been there
as long as I have
um they're not receiving the mental
health treatment that they need
thank you
sorry
um it's also really important in terms
of recruiting new lawyers
um Kara talks a lot about this she
actually works as a clinical professor
at UNH she is basically training our
incoming class before they even get to
us and she has seen that there's a
movement in the universities towards the
well-being of lawyers of making sure
that they have access to mental health
care and so you see the incoming class
expecting that care expecting that
they're going to be able to attend
therapy and they ask me about it when
we're doing new lawyer training and I
have to be honest with them and I have
to say to them you're probably not going
to be able to afford to go to a
therapist on your salary I I can't
afford it on my salary
um and that's really hard for them to
hear and if there are other programs or
other jobs that are offering that we are
going to lose lawyers that are the best
and the brightest because of that
um she wasn't able to submit it prior
but we I also got a letter from Eva
farakkas who is a new lawyer she just
started in the national office who
writes about that who writes that she
saw the benefits packet and thought
about not coming to nhpd because of it
but decided that she was going to make
it make do but she was attending therapy
and is no longer and at times has had to
go to the doctor and hasn't because she
can't afford to go
um
inflammation I do think putting us on
this bill will help us retain and
recruit lawyers that is how we can lower
our caseloads that's how we can lower
overall costs as Sarah said it takes a
lot of time effort and money resources
to train a new lawyer if I leave the
program you can't just hire someone to
replace me they can't take my caseload
it's going to take years before they can
take the cases that I have
and and we're not going to be able to
recruit some of the best and brightest
who will Who will stay and who will want
to make this program as good as it is
and again it is a great program and it
is you know we're such a small state and
we have such a great public defenders
and I just want to stay to make it
better
thank you
thank you very much questions
seeing none thank you
Leah krauser
good morning I don't generally have a
problem with my volume so let me know if
I'm wrong about that
I've worked at a staff attorney at the
New Hampshire public defender for almost
seven years now
during that time I've seen turnover
at first
at a normal rate something you can
expect something that's in every kind of
uh job market but then as the years went
on the pandemic complicated the judicial
system stalled the courts and strategic
choices were made caseloads skyrocketed
um and I mean that I was over two and a
half times my expected caseload
mental health plummeted as a result and
job satisfaction faltered and
deteriorated
we've lost far more than a third of our
attorneys in this short amount of time
and not just attorneys or bodies to take
cases but the institutional knowledge
that goes with them
the ability to train the new class to
Mentor them to keep them on
at my seven year mark I am currently
mentoring two new attorneys that is
strange it is uncommon and it is a huge
time commitment
uh I am responsible for my caseload but
also theirs their appearances in court
their clients and why do I have to
because there's no one else to do it
we have no mid-level attorneys that have
the experience
the time the mental energy to do this
the more we fail at retention keeping
people in my experience level in
eliana's experience level the more
caseloads will rise and the more people
that will leave because the job is just
that hard
it feels like a never-ending cycle
but we're at least starting we have a
glimmer of hope to change that cycle
many attorneys and staff members have
written stories or come to me about
their current experience with our health
insurance and what it would mean to be
on the state health insurance plan
they've talked about the harm our
insurance has caused them and their
families and the promise this bill
offers and I want to Echo that while
caseloads are a really big concern and
salaries are also a really big concern
health insurance is part of the entire
compensation package
salaries take into account other
benefits and people can live with less
if they receive the health care that
they need
the first story I want to talk about is
from a staff attorney that left New
Hampshire public defender last year
she left in very large part due to the
complications from our health insurance
the beginning of her affordability
issues with the public defender's office
began toward the end of her first year
of employment when she tried to enroll
in therapy at the time she says it was
partially because I needed it and
partially a preventative measure because
she knew how hard the job could be
she wanted to make sure she had the help
in place for when she needed it and her
case so it got more serious
therapy visits cost her eighty dollars
per visit
even with an in-network provider
with a beginning salary on the New
Hampshire public defender salary scale
she could only afford one visit per
month
she made the choice against her doctor's
recommendation to only go once per month
because that's what she could afford
on the state plan she could have
afforded weekly visits and the monthly
costs would have still been lower than
her one session
in her second year she had an emergency
hospitalization that caused her to hit
her deductible all at once resulting in
thousand dollar thousands of dollars of
bills she could not afford to pay
she was living paycheck to paycheck as
an attorney with the New Hampshire
public defender and this put her over
her budget
she was lucky that she had a family that
could help but she talks about the
embarrassment of having to go to them
for help
she was the first generation that had
professional degrees and she couldn't
even support herself or get basic
Medical Care
she knew when she went to them she was
going to have to defend her decision to
work as a public defender in New
Hampshire to them
because she couldn't support herself
under the state health insurance plan
she says that her deductible would have
been low enough that she could have
afforded the emergency hospitalization
when she returned to work the stress
from both the job the time off and the
added bills compounded the already
stressful work
and it solidified her decision to leave
and seek other employment she could no
longer afford her job at the public
defender
the second letter or story I brought to
talk to you about is from someone who is
still at the New Hampshire public
defender but her ability to stay at the
public defender is directly tied to the
bill before you
she's been at the public defender for
five years her co-worker she says are
like her family and it's what kept her
here
but in summer of 2022 she couldn't put
off medical appointments any longer she
had heart issues that she could no
longer ignore her cardiologist and
gastroenterologist requested multiple
procedures in testing in order to get
her a diagnosis
our health insurance denied the
procedures her doctors deemed were
necessary they found a mass in her
stomach
but Cigna would not pay for the more
precise diagnostic test to determine its
nature because quote there was no proof
that mass would grow in the next 12
months
not having a definitive answer has led
this co-worker to take more leave more
sick days and has impacted her ability
to do the job
it has put a burden on her her
co-workers and the rest of the employees
and she has the added stress of not
knowing what's going on with her own
health
based on this alone she says it's
difficult to stay in the job and to not
look for a better
better benefits elsewhere
I have seen multiple lawyers in my time
here leave because of the benefits
package or at least a component being
the benefits package
the mental health care that is necessary
to do this job appropriately and not
burn out and be able to stay at this job
is is high it requires us actively
seeking those those services that are
financially kind of Out Of Reach from
what we're able to pay
I fear new lawyers who start and
encounter a similar experience as those
I've talked about may be discouraged
from remaining here long term from
choosing to have children like Ellie
Eliana has said or from not receiving
the medical care they need to be able to
stay in the job at all
the bill before the committee can make a
meaningful difference
it can stop the hemorrhaging of
Attorneys at the New Hampshire Public
Defender
and keep attorneys support staff and be
a real benefit in recruitment
it can make us competitive with other
state agencies and other public defender
agencies that are taking our our staff
that we have trained and that we cannot
keep within the state
I'd ask you to consider these stories
and others that you will hear and I
really thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions
thank you madam chair if my question is
not appropriate please let me know
um would you you were talking about
deductibles how much is a family plan or
a single plan that you pay now I don't
know the answer I'm not on our health
insurance
okay
very good representative Orion do you
have a question yes when
when the attorneys leave the public
defender office where do they typically
typically go to a private
Financial eternity form or a different
area of law where are they going then I
think it depends
um most attorneys I know are going to
State agencies in New Hampshire or
Massachusetts uh where they get the
state health insurance or they're going
to cpcs the public defender in
Massachusetts
um or they're going into private
practice or working in small firms
almost anywhere okay thank you other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on Senate bill 108.
all right
seeing none I will close the public
hearing we are into the time for the
next bill so we will consider this at
our executive session this afternoon we
don't have time to do it right now
um so I'm hoping that the hearing on
Senate bill
yes
thank you madam chair I just want to
make a comment to all the public
defenders
I've sat here since uh January and this
is the first time I've cried through
testimony having worked in Juvenile
Justice my friends all wondered why I
didn't go get on the child and family
committee I just want to say I feel your
pain I know the work you do and thank
you you're the heroes and Juvenile
Justice
okay
so I'm opening the hearing on
Senate bill 105.
and I call the sponsor Senator Rosenwald
thank you madam chair
and members of the committee for the
record I'm Cindy Rosenwald I represent
Senate District 13 which is most of
Nashua
and I'm pleased to introduce Senate bill
105. this bill grew out of a study
committee last summer and fall and
um the house co-sponsors were members of
that subcommittee with me
so
um
when a woman gives birth in New
Hampshire the division of Vital Records
which is located in the Secretary of
State's office collects information
needed to issue a birth certificate
however the form the off the mother is
required to fill out for the birth
certificate also forces her to divulge
some very personal information
to the Secretary of State such as how
much she smoked while she was pregnant
how much alcohol she drank and even how
much she weighed before she got pregnant
and the form tells her it's a felony to
lie about any of this I've given you all
a copy of this form
um
Vital Records doesn't want it to be made
public but I've highlighted some of the
questions mothers are asked to answer
and I've also highlighted the felony
warning for lying which occurs most of
the way down
the page on the mother's worksheet for
the birth certificate
so
you are forced to divulge
your personal habits and some of your
medical history under threat of criminal
penalties
as if this is not intrusive enough
sometime after the mother goes home
the hospital or birthing center sends
out more identifiable confidential
health information from the mother and
her baby's medical records to the
division of Vital Records without her
permission and most likely without even
telling her this information includes
when was her last period does she have a
sexually transmitted disease is she
breastfeeding even a little bit did she
have fertility treatments was it a
vaginal birth
and many other personal questions about
her medical and social history again
I've highlighted some of this personal
identifiable information taken from her
and her baby's medical records and sent
to the Secretary of State and the
Centers for Disease Control
and that those questions are on the
facility worksheet that follows the
mother's worksheet
state law in the
332-i has long made clear that the
information in someone's medical records
belongs to that person
the provider owns the physical record
but the individual owns what's in it and
it the sentence could not be more clear
and it's long time stay long so let me
emphasize that the information in
someone's medical records belongs to
them not the hospital
not any doctor
and not the government
furthermore a few years back five years
ago more than 80 percent of Voters
amended the New Hampshire Constitution
to include a statement that granted
Staters have
the right quote to be free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information end quote
providers that release a patient's
medical information not for the HIPAA
purposes of treatment payment or
Essential Health Care operations without
that person's consent or violating 332 I
and I believe they are also violating
the New Hampshire Constitution
we should I think be further concerned
about the invasion of privacy and the
security of this medical information
released to the division of Vital
Records because the Secretary of State's
office is not covered by yahepa I don't
have any concerns about their internal
management controls at all however any
hacking or breach of their systems would
not be subject to the investigative
enforcement or penalties in HIPAA the
individual whose confidential medical
information was wrongly accessed would
have no protection at all
and the what I think is an unauthorized
clearly unauthorized disclosure of
individuals medical history is not
limited to state government
for two years during the study committee
and through the Senate phase of work on
this bill both the division of Vital
Records and the division of Public
Health in the Department of Health and
Human Services told us that only
de-identified information on Mothers is
sent to the National Center for Health
statistics which is part of the CDC
um that is not the case
all of this identifiable health
information is sent to the federal
government omitting only her name
her address her date of birth her place
of birth among other identifiers is sent
to the federal government making it very
simple to identify individual women and
tie that to their Mana Court histories
I have read the cdc's instruction manual
for hospitals on how to fill out the
birth worksheets to send the federal
government four times I didn't give it
to you but it's incredibly detailed it
has eight different ways diabetes has to
be reported and nine different
classifications for reporting
hypertension
for artificial insemination it requires
hospitals to report whether the sperm is
from the husband or a donor and remember
this is identified information with the
mothers
all of her identity except her name
um but nowhere in its 59 pages
does it require that identifying
information on women who give birth be
disclosed to the CDC but yet we send it
for about 25
000 mothers and babies in New Hampshire
every year
now I would like to ask the men on this
committee to imagine for a moment what
if you had let's say erectile
dysfunction or perhaps an enlarged
prostate causing frequent urination or
you like to have a few drinks or maybe
you're somewhat overweight
and this information with your identity
attached is was disclosed to the
division of Vital Records and the
federal government without your
permission or even your knowledge
and then in the impossible event of a
breach there were not even the
protections of HIPAA I don't think you
would find this acceptable but that's
the situation the women of New Hampshire
are in
so Senate Bill 105 aims to rectify this
situation in two ways one it
decriminalizes the mother's worksheet
that she has to fill out and remember
you fill it out you're not in the
hospital for a very long a day or two
you've just had a baby maybe you're
tired maybe you're overwhelmed maybe
you're more interested in your baby so
it decriminalizes that information
should you decide not to report what you
weighed before you were pregnant and it
de-identifies the information the
hospitals released to the Secretary of
State the division of Vital Records
which is also released to the CDC
Senate Bill 105 recognizes the
importance of de-identified data that
DHHS and doctors who do research use to
understand maternal and child health in
New Hampshire they will still have
access to all the categories of
information they currently get how many
women have cesarean sections have
fertility treatments have gestational
diabetes or other complications use
drugs the number of babies born with
exposure to substances that have to be
reported to dcyf they just won't have
identifying information along with those
records and let me reinforce also that
all this Health Data will still be sent
to the CDC they just won't get the
identities of New Hampshire's mothers
and babies involved now you'll be
hearing from the Department of Health
and Human Services and some doctors and
Clinics they're all behind me there's a
large group this morning that they're
worried about losing Federal money and
the impact this might have on public
health programs I recognize the
importance of federal grants
as for the threat of losing federal
grants I have been here long enough to
remember a long and drawn out debate on
the house floor about all the federal
money we were told we would lose if we
did not pass a mandatory seat belt
needless to say you know we didn't pass
it and we have never lost those federal
funds
I personally worry that the department
and some doctors are more concerned
about the loss of money and their own
work than they are about invading the
privacy of women and babies and taking
something that does not belong to them
Mr chair
and members of the committee we must
remember that someone's medical
information
belongs to them not the hospital
not the doctor and not the state of New
Hampshire and certainly not the federal
government
in the end it is their constitutional
right to be free from governmental
intrusion in their private or personal
information and is also their legal
right because under New Hampshire law
their medical history belongs only to
them thank you and be happy to answer
questions thank you Senator I'm sure
there'll be some yes representative
Lucas
thank you
um and welcome thank you so as a
co-sponsor of this I certainly supported
the bill as introduced what I'm
wondering if you can uh Enlighten us is
to
why the Senate amended it as it did
so the
agenda
allowed
the mother to
refuse consent for her
medical information to be disclosed to
the division of Vital Records
um and based on testimony we heard from
the Department
that they thought it was very important
to get a complete set of Statistics we
amended it so that all this information
is still has to be reported to the
division of vital record for use by DHHS
and researchers and doctors around the
state but it will be de-identified so it
really won't be personal to a particular
individual great thank you
representative Gerhard thank you
chairman
while I admire your efforts to keep
medical information private I was
looking at an old NH New Hampshire
Public Radio article when they were
talking about the New Hampshire veterans
home and well the Federal Department of
Veterans Affairs was requiring 115 000
of their front line workers to get
vaccinated for the coveted with the
coveted vaccine and in that article it
writes late last week Senator Cindy
Rosenwald the national Democrats cited
the same goal goal when she called on
sununu to require the staff and the
state's veterans homes representative
gerhardt is this relevant to this bill
I'm just concerned about the desire to
keep medical information private but
requiring people to be vaccinated with a
vaccine that's been proven to be a
complete failure I'm just con thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you so much thank you
very much
uh representative tour
character thank you
okay
uh hey thanks
um I am uh appreciate the opportunity to
speak before the committee about this
um I am represent Brentwood
um I'm also here basically representing
um as an individual who has you know
about 30 years of Public Health
Consulting experience with uh the state
of New Hampshire a variety of other
states around the country
federal government
um
a lot of it focused on data analysis
I've worked with both Vital Statistics
and with HIPAA protected information
from from the state
um you know and I work on issues related
to access to health care including rural
Health
um analysis
um I am here to oppose the changes as
they are currently
embodied in in the amended Bill uh
I think if the issue surrounds HIPAA
there and and if this data that's been
discussed is not covered by HIPAA I
think that is a valid issue that
probably should be addressed through a
variety
of means but the
um content of the data versus the
security of the data are two separate
issues
um
HIPAA explicitly allows Public Health
disclosure of personal health
information
and birth outcome data the full set of
it is one of the most basic sort of
fundamental public health statistics
that's used across a wide variety of of
both programs and public health analyzes
so I think the presence of the
identifiable information in birth record
data
is inherent it's critical to the use of
the information
and the linkage of that data
um I the the way I see it is focused on
two things that would be lost one is the
ability to link to geography
um
Statewide statistics are not uh
particularly useful in this in this
realm
um and often we're looking for things at
a much lower level the other thing is
linkage between
the vital record data and other data
sets you know even down to the level of
the the link birth death records that
that support infant mortality
um
there's a difference between the
government having the ability to make
those linkages and what is disclosed so
it's often the case that I will be
asking for statistics that are at a
level too sensitive to be released but I
can ask the government to aggregate
these statistics for me and give it to
me in an aggregated form that suits my
purposes one one example is uh adhering
to rural health definition used by the
state so we make a distinction between
rural versus non-rural areas
and aggregate the results though that is
done at essentially a town or is it code
level depending on the definition so we
can re-aggregate those numbers based on
the geography without actually releasing
the specifics um about it so if you if
you remove the identifiability of the
data all that that leverage over the
data is
um lost
um so I'm essentially hoping that
there's a way to step back from
sort of the current proposal get the
data covered under HIPAA as it should be
and to keep the content of the
information that's needed for for public
health purposes
um there's a variety of ways in which
that can be done one might be rehousing
the data in a different uh agency the
other might be what Texas is one example
they passed a law that essentially just
said other other entities the hip is
basically a floor for who has to adhere
to
these data security requirements it's
not a ceiling House Bill 300 in Texas
from 2011 is an example it's a quite
broad thing that they did and not
advocating that but
um you know basically said that that
requirement extends to other other
entities besides sort of what HIPAA
establishes if it can't be within a
public health entity
um so I guess in closing I
I just want to say you know working
across the country on issues like this I
would hate for our state to be the one
place where I can't obtain good Public
Health birth information
particularly as we deal with adverse
outcomes for for birth
um
going back to rural our state's lost 12
labor and delivery
um units at our hospitals in the last 20
years uh one of them just within the
last year
um so the the the the
um
delivery system uh that ties to these
birth certificates is very much under
under pressure right now and it's very
much important that we keep access to
being able to tie all this data together
you know being respectful for people's
private private health information it's
not easil it's this data is not easily
obtained when it's when it's covered by
the the health department but it needs
to be accessible
um I'll and I'll end with a really bad
pun and just say don't um throw the baby
out with the bathwater
are there any questions
right seeing none thank you for your
test
representative Horrigan
um
and in your experience
um do research what do researchers go to
Great Lengths to to secure the data and
are they required
which actually I know they are required
to uh
tell you know tell the agency that's
given that you know like the vital
records department here in New Hampshire
and the other states like what what
they're going to do with the data what
security measures are going to have in
place is so is there a process and for
reviewing and enforcing those uh those
precautions
uh thanks
um representative hargan yeah uh in my
experience as as an outside contractor
to state government
um obtaining data that's not in the
publicly available record set
um which basically means you're you're
getting into some of the HIPAA protected
fields that are contained in the data
requires a fairly extensive
um process by which you basically
justify that the data that you're um
requesting is needed for the intended
purpose also HIPAA contains a minimum
minimum necessary standard so they'll
only disclose what sort of absolutely
has to be contained in order to satisfy
the question this question being asked
and uh we have to enter into essentially
a business associate agreement which
puts us at as an organization my company
at Great Financial Risk if we were to
accidentally even lose or disclose that
that data so it's kept on you know
encrypted servers with limited access
very compartmentalized
um when we when we're holding that
information
thank you thanks
all right I don't see any other
questions so thank you for your
testimony thank you representative
McDonald
chairman and colleagues
do turn your mic on please
and your companion introduce yourself as
chairman of Health and Human Services
here in the house I'm always telling
people turn on your mic and here I I
violated one of those Cardinal rules uh
but but that's great to see you all
um accompanying me this morning is
Lindsey bibo she is the administrator of
the special investigations unit at the
New Hampshire Department of Health and
Human Services
um I had the privilege of being part of
that unit for 23 years prior to my
retirement uh in June of 2019
I do have a prepared statement which I
can give to the clerk if you want to
bring it up now or at the end of my
testimony at the end we'll be fine sure
great thank you
but it looks like we have a great number
of people who want to talk to us so
please summarize sure sure it's a fairly
short anyway but basically
um again I'm my name is Wayne McDonald
for the record I'm a state
representative from Rockingham County
District 16 which is the town of
Londonderry I'm also the chairman of the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs and I also
as I mentioned just a moment ago had the
privilege of working for the Department
of Health and Human Services for 23
years as a fraud investigator
and the unit that Mrs bibo currently
oversees I retired as a senior
investigator in June of 2019. I'm fully
aware of the privacy concerns that that
are expressed in this legislation and I
know it it seeks to address and protect
protect those concerns particularly in
this day and age of identity theft how
we use our personal information and to
whom we give it and why has never been
more important than the need to be
careful has never been greater but
there's a legitimate reason why
government agencies collect certain
sensitive information and two two great
examples is the IRS and the Social
Security Administration and it's it's
obvious as to why they need certain
sensitive information HHS here in the
Health and Human Services here in the
state of New Hampshire there's no
exception to that rule
um the ability of uh and speaking
particularly from my background as a
fraud investigator much of that
information that we were able to collect
through various means and that this bill
would would Hinder would would affect
the ability of the department to pursue
overpaid benefits and food stamps and
and cash assistance child care
assistance Medicaid assistance we know
that the Medicaid expenses have never
it's important that we make sure
everybody eligible for Medicaid gets it
but at the same time we don't want to
improperly administer benefits and
that's that's always a concern of any
improperly administered benefits even if
somebody is not on public assistance
the fact is that they could be aiding
and abetting someone and so some of the
information we would be able to get
could affect our ability to pursue
somebody who nonetheless was jointly in
severally liable for a public assistance
debt
um you know in terms of being able to
find out where someone is working if we
have a court order they they aided and
embedded in a welfare fraud they're
jointly insibly liable for this maybe
they weren't on assistance but they
helped by lying about their whereabouts
whether they were in the home or
something or otherwise assisted in the
commission of the fraud so for that
reason
uh this information is very very
important I would much of the
information we're talking about uh was
important to me in 211 211 successful
prosecutions of both a felony and a
misdemeanor nature during my career and
it's very important in terms of
safeguarding public dollars and honoring
our commitment not only to clients uh as
as they relate to the department but
also to the taxpayer the absence of this
critically important information
can also
um you know affect child support in in
terms of their duties to um uh determine
paternity and pursue absent fathers and
or mothers usually it's an absent uh
father but it can be the one
um also uh they have an interstate unit
in the Department of Division of Child
Support and their ability to go across
state lines and pursue uh people would
be affected in that regard also
uh as far as the over a very legitimate
concern over privacy if I could go back
to that for a moment because I it's
something that concerns us all uh it's
important for all of you to know that
all Department employees on onto a very
strict confidentiality requirements the
information the department gathers may
not be used except in the confines of
its specific official responsibilities
personal information is not treated
lightly and it is not misused it's
further my understanding that no other
state has imposed these types of
restrictions as enumerated in this bill
and I suspect the reason is in part for
the concerns I have expressed and so my
colleagues in the interest of the
taxpayers we serve and for that matter
all of our fellow citizens I urge you to
amend this bill and remove section 2 or
vote the entire Bill and expedient to
legislate and that concludes my
testimony Madam chairman
thank you to take questions if you have
any representative Schmidt
mining representative good afternoon
representative it's it's crossed the
noontime hour and return the greeting to
you representative good to see you so
um my question is how many of the
questions on this questionnaire which I
must say I find
extraordinarily intrusive I I've sir I
served for about five or six years on
the vital records privacy board which uh
oversees requests for information
aggregated information that individual
identifiable information but aggregated
information regarding all kinds of
things births deaths
illnesses and so forth so I understand
the extraordinarily valuable uh aspect
of comprehensive information that is
collected about people but I must say I
find this this form
extraordinarily intrusive and my
question is how much of this can a can a
person who's filling it out say
won't answer that won't answer that
won't answer that
and because
some of this stuff I mean Senator
Rosenwald in her testimony
hypothesized several uh questions that
uh that might be asked of a male
um and
um and and many of them just glancing
through this are as I say
extraordinarily intrusive
and while it might be very interesting
and in political or important for the
state and the government to know about
it
putting it all down on a on a form like
this with your name date of birth social
security number and all that makes you
that Nails you down Nails the person
down
unmistakably uh is like a ticking Time
Bomb I think regardless of all the
the guarantees that you've referenced
the ticking Time Bomb because it has
your brother Schmidt what is your
question my question I already asked the
question okay I already asked the
question but I'm saying that this is
once you put your name on it
and handed away you've you've handed uh
a ticking Time Bomb away in my opinion
so what on this form can uh the the the
mother in this case can she refuse to to
answer she can't tell a lie according to
the form yes thank you but can she can
she answer your question yeah
representative Schmidt uh the department
could probably answer that better than I
can I don't know there are several
people from the Department uh but uh
it's my understanding that this this
section too that we're most concerned
about restricts the ability of the
department to collect the information
but that if him can correct me or
perhaps someone else can who follows
that they can't be compelled to give
some of the information but that um
this would hinder the ability of the
department to even collect it and all of
this I can assure you is relevant to the
various investigations over 2300
investigations I conducted all of this
was very relevant very useful very
carefully safeguarded and it would be
unfortunate to lose this information
um you know and and be uh you know in
terms of being able to collect the
literally millions and millions of
dollars the the special investigations
unit
specifically was able to bring back to
the stake office
so I believe there is some some refusal
ability on the part of a client of an
individual but um in terms of the
Department's ability to collect this
information
um you know it nonetheless is important
I don't know if I've answered your
question Mira no that helps thank you
thank you thank you other questions
representative Horrigan
that's like I actually I am currently
serving on the board that representative
Schmidt mentioned and um
how do you um
but so I understand
um you know there's privacy concerns and
you do protection simply so how do you
balance um those against the fact that
especially when you have a health
emergency like the covid
pandemic it's useful to have very
detailed information in order to combat
a lot of the misinformation that goes
around looking thank you good thanks
Jennifer again thanks like in the case
of that yeah it was definitely it was a
respiratory virus and that there were
excess deaths and I'm not yeah in terms
of misinformation I'm not sure you mean
if they they provided false information
is that what you mean um I'm not sure I
understand your question well also well
not so much that but also sometimes
people will expel those theories that
aren't actually supported but
please don't Hector the the the
testifier
didn't mean to do that no but
um and again if the information they
give us is accurate it can sometimes
support suspicions if it's inaccurate
it's it's further false information that
can be used in a potential prosecution
effort or a um an administrative
disqualification effort that that would
go through the administrative Appeals
Unit
um you know so I I uh I I was not in the
unit during the pandemic and Mrs bibo if
you're able to testify in terms of speak
at all to the how the unit function
during the pandemic
well I I would like to clarify that if a
mother does misrepresent or or withhold
information on this form that is out of
the outside of the purview of what
special investigations unit does we
would not we are not the unit that would
try and enforce there are other portions
of HHS that have said they will be
testifying so right we can't uh we can't
testify to that thank you
I someone has a question okay thank you
very much
okay thank you
okay
and I would encourage the other people
to uh
to focus their testimony
Mary uh bidgood Wilson
want me to bring this up Madam chairman
please
good afternoon my name is Mary good
Goodwills and I'm the family nurse
practitioner and a certified nurse
Midwife I practiced at lace region for
the last 35 years
excuse me
sorry
um I practiced at the Lakes Region area
for the last 35 years and was a member
of the medical staff at Lakes Region
Healthcare no Concord Hospital Laconia
currently I serve as the chair of the
legislative Commission on
interdisciplinary Primary Care Workforce
the commission was established in 2010
to plan and advocate for policy change
relate related to maintaining and
strengthening an effective Primary Care
Workforce in New Hampshire with special
concerns for Rural and underserved areas
members represent a wide array of health
professionals in Primary Care the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services will provide many examples of
the consequences of Senate Bill 105
would have on many programs and funding
the impact of the data collection would
be significant the 2022 Report on health
status of rural residents in the health
Workforce data collection revealed
maternal Health disparities in our state
primarily when comparing the
Winnipesaukee area to the race of
overall Rule and non-rule the rate of no
or late prenatal care is almost two
times higher without access to this data
from Vital Records the state wouldn't
have no way of assessing or tracking
maternal Health discrepancies in the
state
this data allows Public Health to inform
policy and Target resources
appropriately Additionally the vital
health information allows the state to
understand and track maternity care
deserts birthing Hospital location does
not account for the distance traveled
for birth without this data New
Hampshire would not be able to determine
where parents are traveling from
removing the opportunity to create
better access late entry into prenatal
care is a red flag for poor birth
outcome the timely report of 2022 allows
for early intervention to affect the
entry into prenatal care this is just
one example of the negative consequences
of the impact of Senate Bill 105 will
have on Health Care in New Hampshire and
I urge you to vote no I'm happy to
answer your questions and again thank
you for the opportunity to address the
commission
and I would just like to add one other
thought after hearing some of the
testimony
um
having filled that report out three
times earlier in my life
um I understand that it would be a
little bit like well how many drinks did
you have a day but without that data we
never would have uncovered fetal alcohol
syndrome and over the last 25 to 30
years we wouldn't have provided the
counseling to patients of the importance
of not drinking when they were pregnant
so I just wanted to clarify that
thank you representative Gerhard thank
you madam chair just curious I don't
know if you can answer this but can you
be prosecuted for the answers you give
to that questionnaire
I have never heard of anyone being
prosecuted for being for the answers
that they gave to that questionnaire
thank you thank you
thank you very much you're very welcome
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so I apologize for
speaking so much sharply to you that if
you don't speak into the microphone we
can't hear you and you're being recorded
so that people who are watching and so
forth so I apologize for speaking so
much sharply uh but but your testimony
is very very informative and many of the
things you referenced in your final
remark are part of the person's medical
record are they not yes okay in other
words that that the the scientific
discoveries that were based on
you say on the on fetal alcohol syndrome
yeah that's an example of it yes uh some
of the things that this form is very
intrusive uh in asking uh it would also
be in the person's medical record
separately would it not
well yes it would be but there would be
no data collection from the person's
private medical record
the data collection is from the birth
report the birth certificate report
but I'm very concerned about the Privacy
aspect I understand so is there not a
possibility that that the form could be
divided into things that are mandatory
and it would serve the purpose you're
talking about
but would not be intrusive in terms of
some of the stuff that that I
might be I'm sure it's helpful to the
authorities to know but you're asking
people to basically lay their lives bare
in many many respects and I have a
concern about that
I I understand I think that people from
the Department could probably answer
that question with complete accuracy but
I understand that it's a national data
collection system in all 50 states use
the same collecting mechanism but they
really are the experts not me about that
thank you
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh David Wieters from HHS
you just turned your microphone off
that's better thank you
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee thank you for having me here
my name is David Wieters I'm the
information Services director for Health
and Human Services
and some of my testimony will make more
sense after director Tilly presents but
then we'll call you back later great
thank you
all right
Patricia Tilley
thank you good afternoon chair good
afternoon members of the committee my
name is Patricia Tilley I am the
director of the division of Public
Health Services at the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
uh and good afternoon my name is uh Ben
Chan I am the state epidemiologist at
the New Hampshire Department of Health
and Human Services and also a physician
thank you I'm going to try what Dave
Wieters just did to get out of speaking
in the future but um it was a great
great strategy uh thank you for the
opportunity to provide additional
information about Senate Bill 105 and
the way that it would have unintended
impacts on the residents of New
Hampshire today Dr Chan and I are here
to consid to ask you to consider to
either itl the bill in front of you or
modify it in such a way to further
protect privacy and ensure that Granite
Staters still can continue to easily
access the level of public health health
care and economic supports that they
receive today specifically section two
of the bill is unworkable we are just a
few of the many individuals here today
deeply concerned that section 2 may
impact not only our funding but the
public health health care delivery and
economic supports of real individuals in
your communities notably sections one
and four of the bill can work hand in
hand with existing privacy and security
governance and existing New Hampshire
and federal statutes including HIPAA
standards in particular we are very
comfortable with section one which
removes the penalties for the health
questions
I've broken my golden rule of only
providing short and sweet testimony
today you'll see that the written
testimony in front of you is over eight
pages long I am not going to read that
um but the reason why the testimony is
so dense is because the wide reaching
impacts of the bill as we have
researched and talked to Partners we
continue to peel back the onion about
the many ways SB 105 would weaken the
foundation of services that individuals
use every day from access to care at a
federally qualified Health Center to
ensuring that your baby has the right
screening services in the hospital to
accessing child support and so much more
importantly the privacy of this
sensitive data is already protected by
existing state and federal statutes and
the strong data governance systems that
are in place both at the Secretary of
State's office and the Department of
Health and Human Services chapter law 5
C4 states that the Registrar of Vital
Records shall consider the protection of
the privacy of individuals about whom
information is given and to underscore
represented rosenwald's testimony no
names are sent to CDC or the national
Center of health statistics since 1907
the United States has used the data in
birth certificates to ensure citizenship
proof of age to prevent child labor and
to prevent fraud for entitlement
programs and government benefits in
accordance with the federal Public
Health Service Act all 50 states now ask
a standard set of questions this is to
ensure inter-jurisdictional exchange if
I am a New Hampshire resident and I have
my baby in Massachusetts data can easily
be exchanged and understood here in New
Hampshire if I am a Vermont resident and
I have my baby here in New Hampshire
similarly the birth record must be
standardized with your Indulgence I'm
going to talk about just a little bit
about the four areas that have
significant financial and statutory
implications of this bill as an
unintended consequence of section 2
there are critical services at risk when
we de-identify elements of birth
certificate data I'm also going to
highlight the programmatic areas of the
state that would be at risk for fraud as
representative McDonald noted because we
may not have a complete data set to
compare eligibility applications to or
use for investigation there are a number
of other existing statutes that are in
conflict with Senate Bill 105 that would
need to be changed if section 2 were
enacted and of course there's money
um you know the federal funds both DHHS
and the Secretary of State's office
would lose for programs and data system
modernization because New Hampshire
would no longer have complete data you
can shrug your Collective shoulders at
less money for the state oh well or the
sky is falling but fewer federal funds
means fewer basic supports like high
quality Health Care prenatal care in
your communities for your constituents
these programs have real life
consequences if New Hampshire does not
have complete birth records as section 2
is written it is unclear how data will
be exchanged with these Social Security
Administration
currently all infants automatically
receive their social security number
because States send birth records to the
Social Security Administration if
enacted it is possible that all 12 000
New Hampshire families a year who have
babies would need to then bring hard
copies of their birth certificate to
facilitate the issuance of their social
security number for their infant this is
going to be a significant hardship on
families and the Social Security
Administration federally qualified
health centers in order to receive
federal support to provide low-cost care
for almost 90 000 individuals in the
state
fqhcs must be in federally designated
medically underserved areas there is a
complex Federal formula that uses local
birth data to determine eligibility of
where you can have an fqhc additionally
New Hampshire supplements their funding
with Federal maternal and child health
funds which are also based on local
birth data without substate data which
would not be allowed if section 2 went
in as described that money very well may
go away when the money stops flowing
access is reduced your constituents will
not get the same prenatal care Primary
Care at places like ammonusic community
health centers kowas family health
amoscake health Lamprey Services there
are real world consequences to this
bureaucratic information we've heard
about the crucial need for local data
which needs residents in order to
protect maternal Health in communities
that have lost their local labor and
delivery services in their hospitals
right now there is a giant swath across
the middle of our state from Claremont
across all the way over towards
Rochester where we no longer can have a
baby simply subbing in the residents of
the address of the hospital gives you no
idea of the health status of of that
entire middle section of the state
similarly hundreds of families who
receive voluntary home visiting services
that provide support parenting education
to families all of which have been known
to reduce child abuse no longer would be
able to receive those services in your
communities If We Can't Describe the
impact of the services at the community
level the discretional federal funding
goes away Services vanish newborn
screening this is critically important
all 12 000 babies born every year
receive timely screenings for conditions
that have not caught before there are
symptoms there are devastating negative
Health outcomes because this is so
important the department has a statutory
responsibility obligation to ensure that
every baby that is born has access to
that screening within 24 hours of birth
we use the birth record every single day
to make sure no baby gets left behind it
isn't an overstatement that without this
process seamless that is seamless less
and invisible to most of us infant lives
are truly at risk maternal mortality
section two with section two the
department is no longer going to have
access to Vital Records data to verify
the death certificate data identify and
assess the cause of death to and to
support preventative programs and
education as a result of these reviews
the infant birth data is required to
appropriately link maternal deaths we
can't guess about this as maternal
mortality Rises across this country we
can't afford to guess without with
section two of the bill we will not have
complete data to understand infant
mortality maternal mortality prematurity
low birth weight perinatal substance
exposure and so much more when you the
legislator asks us to tell them about
any one of those issues or to evaluate
the effectiveness of services
we would just have to say we don't know
or kind of guess the impacts of
information related to the impact of
losing labor and delivery is incredible
we won't be able to easily access easily
and accurately compare Medicaid data to
to the rest of the state and much more
without the mother's residence or town
or city public health will not be able
to release statistics by county or city
we won't know information from
Manchester we won't know information for
kellas County we won't under know about
information for the communities who
serve
without complete data CDC has informed
us that New Hampshire will be removed
from all national data sets we would not
be able to compare New Hampshire
outcomes with those from every other
state
isn't just a public health problem there
are entitlement and Regulatory functions
and activities throughout the department
that will not be able to be completed if
the department does not have that
complete data set director Kieran Karen
here but I'm going to do the same thing
I'm going to show back to somebody else
is available to speak to this about what
we would not be able to do in the
division of Economic Security without
that record importantly things like
child support activities Medicaid fraud
prevention the fully identified birth
data is a backup to ensure that these
systems work is intended and there is no
fraud or abuse without access to names
dcyf is no longer able to independently
verify parentage
dcyf uses this information for
international adoptions which is a
requirement of the federal government
the federal level the census will have
inaccurate population estimates for
state county town and local levels
New Hampshire residents of all age are
going to be affected when programs like
dcyf Medicaid child support cannot
access timely and complete information
potentially life-saving Services may not
be provided and the state is at risk for
fraud
without going into detail and I won't
because my time is short section 2
directly impacts and conflicts with
additional existing statutes and rsh 126
and 5c that all would need to be
addressed section 2 would require A
thorough review of existing statutes
we and finally there is the money our
fiscal note which you can read on your
own time describes in detail what
federal grants would be in significant
Jeopardy without the ability to analyze
complete birth data there is estimate it
is estimated to be tens of millions of
dollars that would not be available
we all agree that privacy is important
and Dave Wieters I'll punt it back to
him is available to describe all the
ways we guard and protect data this most
important and very private and very
sensitive health information
DHHS is a HIPAA covered entity and
complies with all federal statutes to
protect against the inappropriate
disclosure of private information Mr
readers can also describe the data
governance and stewardship strategies
that are currently in place to minimize
the data elements that individuals may
access while doing legitimate Department
functions to answer a question earlier
can you just see the whole record and
the answer is no if my job is to
investigate one particular thing I can
see this much of the record if my job
however is to do the quality assurance
on the entire birth record as is our
responsibility in statute you will see
more of the record we have strict data
governance that limits and is focused on
data minimization so you only see what
you need to see to do your job
um I'll end by suggesting that section
one of the bill and section four of the
bill both Advance privacy section one is
the section that takes away the uh
criminal penalty for the health area
this is an area that we do not disagree
with there has never been a time in
anyone's understanding where anyone was
prosecuted for a criminal penalty for
saying there were 125 pounds before they
were uh before they were pregnant and
when they were actually 140 that has not
happened we're happy to put that in
statute
section 4 of the bill also further
advances privacy and security by
potentially limiting the the amount of
time that records are kept in a hospital
so I will um sum up right now by saying
section two of the bill is unworkable
for all of those many reasons we are
very concerned for both Public Health
the health care delivery system and the
economic supports of your families
thank you are there any questions
I think not
all right thank you very much I have a
question Madam chair is this going to a
subcommittee this is
way too complicated to handle in one
simple hearing is this going to go
I haven't yet decided which one but it
probably should I
we we need to hear from these people at
greater lengths with regard to specifics
yes representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question and I'm not sure you
can answer it and don't try if you can't
um
I'm trying to understand this form gets
filled out and it's sent to Vital
Records
and then they disclose it to you and you
hold it under hhas under HIPAA rules
sure so that's a great question and you
know the Secretary of State's office who
was the owner of the vital records can
probably provide greater detail but what
happens is the hospitals or the birth
attendant if it doesn't occur in the
hospital completes the forms the forms
get uploaded and sent to Vital Records
electronically
um uh 5c then states that the records
then go to DHHS because we have a
tangible interest in the birth record of
note New Hampshire is the only state in
the country that has Vital Records
outside of the Department of Health 49
other states keep this record within the
Department of Health however we have a
great relationship with Secretary of
State we have an incredibly detailed
memorandum of understanding that
describes how the data moves from point
A to point B and how it is governed
thank you thank you okay
thank you
yes representative grassy
um
question
did you have them done
look over she's gone
very quick
um yes I mean one of the things that
really distressed me I've worked on a
number of Grants over the years in
Stratford County and we have a very
distinct division between Northern
Stratford County and Southern Stratford
County as far as health is concerned and
particularly as far as prenatal care is
concerned and one of the things you said
is that what this is going to do is that
in the future if this is passed and I'm
looking at redistributing money within
Stratford County to direct more Aid to
the northern part of Stratford County
which has more problems that that's
going to be impossible for me to make
that determination
that would be true
um So currently as section two is is
written we would substitute in the
hospital so you would just know where
babies were born Portsmouth Portsmouth
so we would have no information about
Stratford County and the unique needs of
Northern Stratford County versus the
unique needs of Southern Stratford
County
representative true
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so
all this information that you're going
to lose
is because you don't have the name and
address yes so the name so there are two
things there are a number of
complicating things here but I'll answer
the the easy way first without the name
and address specifically the address we
don't know where those people are from
so um in Senator rosenwald's
um bill it says the hospital and this
was a great example in Stratford County
babies in Stratford County frisbee has
just closed its Labor and Delivery
Services we've got Wentworth Douglas and
we've got Portsmouth we don't know where
those people would we would not know
where those people live so we would not
know those that are at higher risk who
did not get adequate prenatal care some
of the questions on that form sound
incredibly intrusive when was your last
menstrual period Ike who wants to answer
that but the reason we answer that is
that directly tells us what prematurity
rates are that's the reason for the um
for the question what section one of the
bill does is take away the criminal
penalties we are all in agreement that
criminal there don't need to be criminal
penalties for that portion however we do
believe there need to be penalties about
the facts of the birth mom dad residence
you and can I just quickly excuse me can
I just quickly add that
um you know I I we obviously share the
goal of protecting personal and health
related information but it also remains
important uh to have access to usable
actionable data and that's one of the
core tenets of Public Health Data and
public health having access to this data
is that we don't hold a data set just
for the sake of having a data set we use
that data to promote Health to protect
individuals health and that's done in a
variety of ways but it requires having
that personal identifiable information
and so you know director Tilly
highlighted many examples of how that
data is used newborn screening in order
to identify babies that are newly born
to ensure that they undergo the
necessary health screening
we use the birth record to report on and
intervene on issues around teen births
for example we need that information in
the in the birth record
um and so the goals of protecting
personal and health related information
while also having access to usable
actionable information are not mutually
exclusive and it becomes important not
only for public health to have access to
it but also our local Hospital health
care and Community Partners For example
for exactly the the reasons that you're
highlighting thanks thank you
yes representative Gould thank you madam
chair
so um
my question has to do with I had heard
that
I had heard a rumor and then something
you said is making me feel the need to
ask
this bill would do nothing to take Vital
Records away from the Secretary of State
and put them in Health and Human
Services is that correct that is correct
thank you okay
anyone else representative Horrigan
admit and um you mentioned um 10 percent
of uh 10 of the babies that are born in
New Hampshire hospitals or to mothers
who live in other states I assume
probably and um conversely ten percent
of the uh
Brothers in New Hampshire giving birth
to babies and uh
in others outside New Hampshire and I
assume that's probably predominantly
Vermont Massachusetts and Maine so what
are
what data do those three states
routinely correct is it similar to this
yeah thank you for that question
representative there's a there's a
Android set of questions that all 50
states ask and so that is the way that
we can have inter-jurisdictional
exchange so again I can I can have my
baby in Massachusetts if I'm a New
Hampshire resident or a Vermont
individual can come to New Hampshire and
have their baby at Dartmouth or
somewhere else
um it's critically important that there
is a standard we work close the
Secretary of State's office Works
closely with the national Center for
Health statistics to make sure that no
matter where you're born in the U.S you
have the same level of information
that's provided within the birth record
yeah representative Gould you have a
quick question it's very quick
um
is do the hospitals fill these out and
paper and then somebody does data entry
or they entered electronically it is
primarily an electronic system now I'm
not probably the best to represent
exactly what happens at the bedside in
the hospital but it is primarily an
electronic system thank you okay thank
you
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
Janet Perkins Howland
foreign
I'm Janet Perkins Holland I'm an OB GYN
at Wentworth Douglas hospital I've had
the great honor of working there for
um upwards of 25 years and delivering
several thousand babies in the great
state of New Hampshire
um
and I am not speaking for my hospital
today I also am a proud member of the
New Hampshire State Medical Society and
I believe that my testimony is in
agreement with their stance
um
I as several people have mentioned for
section one
I am in favor of the idea of removing
criminal penalties
um for these type of things I'm always
in favor of removing criminal penalties
for people who give birth
and that is in the context of supporting
um people I think we're all want to
support women or people who give birth
in our state section two I think is the
problematic part the
intent may be good but the impact is
definitely not I think that it is
absolutely
um
possible to believe in the principles of
privacy
and autonomy
reproductive feed Freedom HIPAA
compliance all these things that have
been mentioned and also be in Stark
opposition to section
um two of this bill
I want just want to highlight the uh the
importance of communication and the
communication that is bi-directional the
safety of our patients is deeply
important to me and hopefully to
everybody in this room
but there is a relationship between the
patient and the care providers the whole
everybody that is uh
um and the staff of the hospital or
providing care to the to the people who
give birth and also for the community
um so this information that we're
getting is not just interesting but also
impactful and it's impactful in uh both
a retrospective way and a proactive way
I've um had the uh honor of being on the
maternal mortality Review Board in New
Hampshire and we go in great detail off
this the data that we receive from the
birth certificates about what
um is had is related to somebody's birth
um and I think it is you might be
surprised at
um
how the relationship between some of
these birth some of these uh Health
um things like smoking or IVF or
anything is actually related substance
use disorder is related to uh the the
outcomes the poor outcomes
um one just a brief example is
the New Hampshire prams
um which is the pregnancy New Hampshire
pregnancy risk assessment monitoring
system is funded by the CDC
um and this is
information that we can't get from
billing data this is information that
the uh is is taken from random sampling
of the birth certificates and it is
gives us information about maternal
Mental Health
preconceptual Health as well but
maternal mental health and so I'm deeply
concerned about the taking away
something like prams because this is
where we get our data about something
like postpartum depression and I think I
probably don't have to tell people in
this room about what the impacts of
postpartum depression is so I think this
the
um section 2 of this bill is incredibly
problematic in terms of
preventing us from improving outcomes
and informing quality and safety
programs at our hospital and across our
state it's harmful so thank you very
much
okay questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
Christian Kennestone
thank you madam chair and honorable
members of the committee so I'm Kristen
kenniston I am the new State Registrar
for Vital Records this is day three for
me so I get to come in and chat with
everybody
um just to put you at ease I was the
city clerk in Lebanon for three years
and prior to that for the prior 12 years
I was in that office for staff
um so I have 15 years of Vital Records
experience before coming into this
position joining me today is Trisha
pietzsu she was the acting registrar for
Vital Records and is also the director
of the elections office and she also
brings to the table 25 years of city
clerk's experience dealing with Vital
Records
and we also have David Scanlon here with
the secretary who is the Secretary of
State
so our office is not taking a position
on this legislation we do believe this
is a policy decision for you to make but
we want to bring to your attention
um some of the unintended consequences
that this could have not only for the
division of Vital Records but also for
the constituents in the state of New
Hampshire who are going to have children
um so just starting on the first section
um I think you've already heard enough
testimony regarding the um the felony
Provisions we don't have anything to
offer on that it doesn't affect the
birth certificate nor does it affect the
Social Security side of things so we're
not going to offer any suggestions there
um section two which as you can see is
having the most Focus if you look at
what's being proposed it's striking the
child's name and the parents names and
their information
that is the information that is used to
create the actual birth certificate so
by striking that information from that
worksheet we can now no longer create
birth certificates
and that's
could be problematic to our constituents
So currently what happens is that
paperwork is filled out at the hospital
and if I'm remembering correctly 19
years ago I did the Green Sheet when I
had my daughter and then the hospital
staff worked with me on the rest of it
if you look at it there are a lot of
boxes that say unknown and so that tells
me that you don't necessarily have to
provide that information
that form once it's completed is taken
to the birth registers at the hospital
and then they key it into a system known
as nevren the neverend database is what
houses all of our Vital Records and and
the vital records statistics
um that is when the parents go to the
clerk's office to obtain a certified
copy of that birth record that's the at
the database that they're accessing to
create that record
so
what's happening now is when the
registrar creates the record they issue
something that's called a parent notice
which does two things that sends the
parent notice to the parent who's on
file so that they can get a preview of
the birth certificate make sure there's
no spelling errors because that does
happen it also tells them that that
birth record is available and they can
go and purchase a copy of it and because
of the way our system works up to as far
back as 1935 is available anywhere in
the state of New Hampshire so if I had a
complication and I had to go an hour
away to a hospital I might not
necessarily want to go back to that
clerk's office to use or to obtain my
certified copy so I could go right down
to my own clerk's office and obtain it
but what's going to happen now is when
they key on the information at the
hospital because they still have to
account for this other information
that's requiring to be captured the
child's name is now going to be entered
as baby boy or baby girl the last name
will be put in as unknown
the parents will all going to be either
unknown or not stated so the only
identifiable part that's going to show
up in that never database for your local
clerk to pull up is going to be the date
of birth the time of birth and the
location which as you can tell there's
nothing to identify that that's even the
correct record for the people that are
requesting it
that's also going to require that the
parents go to the clerk's office where
the event occurred to make any revisions
so that's where they're going to go and
assign a name to their child that's
where they're going to go and have to
prove that they are the parents of that
child for the record
which brings us to another tricky point
where
first of all how does the clerk even
identify that they have the correct
correct child's record before they start
just making amendments to it and second
of all how do you know the person in
front of you is the correct person that
should have access to that record
because they might have given me photo
identification but what can I match that
to so that's um that's something that
needs to be thought of
um the the cost for amendments too so
the amendment process itself can
actually be if it's within the first 14
days of it being filed it's relatively
simple but once you get past that 14
days up to six months it's a ten dollar
fee so now it's we're incurring a cost
to the constituents and they have to
come up with um they might have to come
up with some proofs and that's generally
not but they would still have to go in
fill out the form present their photo
IDs it's going to create something
called a marginal note on that record
and that marginal note stays on the
record forever and it just shows that
while these amendments had to be made to
the record because everything previously
said unknown or not stated
after you hit the six month mark it
becomes much more complicated because
people have to provide proofs of what
the corrections are to be made and every
correction that they're making so the
parents names the child's names places
of birth is going to require two pieces
of proof to prove that that's what the
information should actually be so it
does become quite a process for the
parents if they're not able to get
directly in there so if there was a
complication that prevented them from
showing up they might not go in until
that six month Mark and then they're
going to have all of all of those
corrections to have to make
in the um did I miss anything else on
that section
oh yeah so again the correction
procedure is the local clerk where the
event occurred so there's only so many
clerks in the state where
um we have birthing centers really
so they would have to go there which is
going to be an influx on the local
Municipal resources that it takes a
while it can take up to about 10 to 20
minutes depending on how complicated the
correction can be
so then um the other thing that we were
looking at was Social Security
Administration so because
DHHS has already touched on this I won't
go too much into it but now we do not
have this information to supply the
social security so now the parents are
going to have to go in get their record
amended purchase the certified copy and
then do it the manual way to get their
social security cards issued for their
children either by mailing it in or
showing up in person to do this at the
Social Security offices right now you
just check a box and if you say yes I
want it to go the parents are going to
get that Social Security card in the
mail within a few weeks usually a month
so that is now creating that hardship
for the parents
in 2022 just so you know we had over 12
000 children that were born of those
over the 12 000 people only 52 didn't
request a Birthright or excuse me a
social security number for their child
and that could be because they didn't
agree on a name so they did just name
their child baby boy or baby girl or
something happened with the filing that
prevented them from um doing the social
security number
let's see
and it'll also cause some confusion for
the parents as well so if you have
people that have had previous children
before now all of a sudden they're not
getting their social security cards in
the mail they're not getting that parent
notice they're expecting that now so now
they won't be having that
is there anything else you can think of
to add on that section
okay
um so then the third and final section
that we just want to touch on was the
records retention for maintaining those
birth worksheets so the worksheets are
actually maintained by the hospital we
don't get them at all and so right now
it's to maintain them permanently at the
hospital we don't have any um any
concerns that these aren't being kept
permanently our recommendation though is
to at least ask them to keep them for
seven years and our reason for that is
because there is something in the state
called a delayed birth we're actually
dealing with quite a few of them right
now so if a child is born in a hospital
and it's been more than a year and it we
find out oh no the child's information
was never input into neverend
um they have to file a delayed birth
they have to come up with proofs of this
child actually being born it's it's four
proofs and one of the proofs that's
obviously a very good proof to have is
this document right here so that's why
we're just maintaining we recommend
seven to maintain because most people if
they don't get their birth records raid
off they do it when they register
children for school so seven years seem
to be a decent amount of time
um as far as any costs uh is for the
legislation it's it's kind of minimum on
our department
um the bill doesn't appropriate any
funds for the implementation nor are
these costs included in the budget
passed by the house uh there would be a
one-time cost approximately of a hundred
and thousand dollars for system changes
that would be needed within the neverend
system
and then with various contracts and
agreements with entities such as the CDC
and the Social Security we receive
roughly 160 000 a year for reporting
that information
the CDC uses the birth data each state
provides to analyze Trends Trends
Nationwide all states provide this
information these funds are used to
support the operations of our divisions
and would need to be replaced with the
general funds so there might be a
position say that's partially funded or
fully funded by these funds that are
coming in and that person is still going
to stay on with the division now we have
to come up with the funds to keep them
on
so that is the end of my testimony does
anyone have any questions
yes representative Schmitz
so it seems like we're going to have a
subcommittee so I hope you'll be
available for the subcommittee
um what happens with uh people who have
home births or to use doulas in some
kind of a non-hospital situation all
these records and all this data has to
be obtained and how does how does that
happen so that does not be appear to be
affected At All by this bill but it's
essentially the same way the midwives
are given the exact same worksheets and
then that information is used by our
department to key the record on to the
system
because there isn't a birth registrar to
do that cover that representative Gould
thank you madam Sharon thank you for
taking my question
um
you you mentioned keeping the green form
for seven years if the parents don't
request the birth certificate at the
time the child is born is that correct
well just to clarify I'm recommending
that the hospitals still have to keep
them so that there is a backup just in
case they are not aware that the record
wasn't filed they might not become aware
um until they go to get the copy to
register the children for school so the
seven years was that kind of window
where we thought yep so they meaning the
parents might not be aware yeah so my
question is
the green if the hospital doesn't keep
the green form and the parents did not
ask for the birth certificate the data
no longer exists it didn't get entered
into the system we would then have to
file something I called a delayed birth
which is a completely different
process and no the data never enters the
neverend system at that point it's a
it's a manual process that we have to go
through at the local Clerk's level and
then with us okay so I'm a genealogist
too sorry I understand all the delayed
stuff so the the issue is
the hospital fills out the form but if
the parent doesn't want the birth
certificate at the time of birth then
the information the data from the sheet
never gets entered into the data no it's
not that the parent doesn't want it it's
that an error occurred so that they they
might have just made an error and
thought they keyed it into the system
and okay I gotcha thank you
yes hey
I think yes representative true
thank you madam chair
when I was born they just chiseled the
things into the into the concrete who
who issues the birth certificate in New
Hampshire
so it comes out of the neverend system
it can either be issued by my department
the division of Vital Records or it can
be issued from your local clerk City
Clerk or town clerk
follow up thank you madam JS so
if the information from the Green Sheet
is forwarded to your office without the
name and address
you can't do the birth certificate so
what it is it's the birth registrar at
the hospital they won't have that data
to enter it into the database that we
then can retrieve the record with
thank you thank you you're welcome
thank you for your testimony this will
be going to subcommittee uh
representative grotis subcommittee and I
trust that the HHS and Vital Records
will work with us
as we meet
and I'm going to only ask the
individuals who have signed up to speak
to testify
rather not anymore from the agency
because I think we've gotten a flood of
data from them
so
Kaylee Crockett
good morning Madam chair and committee
members my name is Kaylee Crockett and
I'm David Boone and we are here today to
tell you about our unique experiences
um that our family has had with the
newborn screener
so please you you'll have to get closer
to the microphone and speak a little
louder I apologize um we're here to tell
you about our you our family's unique
experiences with the newborn screener
on October 21st 2021 we received a phone
call that our eight day old Son Nolan
had been flagged for a genetic condition
that could be potentially fatal we were
told that the condition was called mps1
which was short for
mucopolysaccharidosis type 1 a genetic
condition that is so rare that most
Physicians do not know about it and in
our state we do not even have a doctor
that treats it Nolan was born into an
incredibly unique situation
his form of mps1 affects one in five
hundred thousand births and is known as
Shea syndrome the mutation that makes up
his condition
has only been documented once before and
that person was not diagnosed until she
was in her 20s
he is the only person in the world to
ever be diagnosed with his form of mps1
prior to the form of on I'm sorry prior
to the onset of symptoms and therefore
prior to needing any sort of treatment
additionally not only is he the only
person to be identified with mps1 in New
Hampshire by the newborn screener he is
also the only person to even be flagged
by as potentially having it in our state
when we received the call in October of
2021 we had been told that we needed to
get our child to Boston Children's
Hospital for further testing the next
morning
they had already set up our appointment
for us we just needed to go down and see
what our next steps would be
after completing several confirmatory
tests it was determined that our son did
in fact have the least severe form of
mps1
where Nolan has such a mild form of the
condition he doesn't have any visible
signs nor does he have any symptoms of
the condition currently
Nolan has six percent of his enzyme
level working this has allowed him to
break down enough of the complex sugar
chains and clear his body of the waste
thus allowing him to not need any
treatments currently
eventually his body will not be able to
keep up and his marginal enzyme level
will stop working causing him to need
weekly treatments for the debrision of
his lifetime
since Nolan was identified to have MPS
via the newborn screener we are very
fortunate to bring him to Boston several
times a year to have his levels tested
so that they can monitor when he will
need to begin his treatment the goal is
to have him begin treatment when his
enzyme level Falls to a level that is
not producing enough
um that he is not producing enough but
is not yet harmful to him
had no one not been identified on the
newborn screener he would have spent
years in and out of different
Specialists trying to determine the
reasoning behind an array of symptoms
the buildup of waste would have caused
him
by the time that a diagnosis was made
the damage already would have been done
and unfortunately there is nothing that
they can do to revert it at that point
to reverse it at that point they can
just treat it from becoming worse
across the country mps1 is not something
that is universally tested for on the
newborn screener the MPS Community is
quite small and we often hear of
children that are not identified as
having the condition until they have
already started developing irreversible
symptoms
taking identifiable information off the
newborn screener will make it that much
more difficult to track families and
inform them in instances where their
child could have potentially fatal
genetic conditions
at eight days old Nolan's life was
forever changed in being flagged by this
condition
and we are forever grateful that we
received this call and are able to
provide him the necessary treatments
it is our hope that you consider not
making any changes to how information is
shared with the newborn screener so that
more families like ours are able to
provide their children with the best
possible outcomes in the timeliest of
manners thank you for your time thank
you for your testimony are there any
questions
seeing none
very good thank you thank you
Jennifer Smith
okay
Lucy hotter
she gave us her testimony thank you
we'll take that in lieu of the speech
Dustin Madam chair one moment um we did
not receive enough copies from Lucy
hotter I'll tell we will get more the
committee members on this side that need
to ask we will make sure we get more
copies
hi good afternoon
for the record my name is deo Danae
Dustin botterey
um I
am a little intimidated surrounding by
all surrounded by all the experts I am
also just speaking as a parent of a
child with a disability
I was born and raised in Kentucky I now
own a home and live in Concord we're
raising our two children there
I'm asking you to oppose this bill I
want to address one program that will be
adversely affected by section two and
that is the newborn screening program
our eight-year-old son has spinal
muscular atrophy SMA this is a
degenerative neuromuscular disorder that
causes his muscles to be very weak and
he navigates the world using a
wheelchair
he's an amazing kid our son's diagnosis
was delayed for months because when he
was born New Hampshire was not screening
for SMA and his newborn screening and so
onset of symptoms occurred
had he been born in Massachusetts where
we they were screening for SMA he could
have been
identified and treated right away and he
likely like other children
um who are
screened and treated before symptom
onset would not be using a wheelchair
today
however
um after my son was finally diagnosed
after his first birthday I began a
years-long effort to have SMA added to
the newborn screening panel here in New
Hampshire and I can happily say that it
has been and that every baby born in New
Hampshire for the last couple years is
screened for SMA is quickly within a
matter of days
given confirmatory Diagnostics and
enrolled in treatment
those who
um so if you pass this bill the
department will no longer be able to
match the newborn screening data daily
with the vital records necessary so that
this time sensitive follow-up can
continue to occur and it this bill in
that way undermines the critical mission
of the newborn screening program
for example so it would cause families
so to wait for results and then that
weight could have dire consequences and
for example children who receive
treatment for SMA prior to symptom onset
are walking running and playing with
their friends
children like mine navigate the world
with a wheelchair but that is the least
of the medical interventions that he
will be going through in his lifetime
the difference between timely diagnosis
through newborn screening and are very
successful program here
and the lack of this notification cannot
be overstated
please do not pass this bill is written
it's a solution and want of a problem
when it comes to newborn screening
program which will be affected the
newborn screening program works and
parents who have concerns around privacy
regarding the newborn screening program
come opt out it's not a mandatory
program
but please don't undermine the
effectiveness of such an amazing
life-saving program
for the majority of Granite State
families who rely on it
I'm happy to answer any questions
regarding that small aspect of this bill
thank you very much I don't see any
questions so thank you for your
testimony
representative Murphy
thank you madam chair members of the
committee excuse me for the record my
name is Nancy Murphy
um I recognize uh representative
Hillsborough uh 12 which is the town of
Merrimack
um I know a lot has been said already so
I'll skip comments about most things but
I just wanted to to voice a concern with
section two of this
um and I'll with a little different take
uh Public Health agencies and
researchers will not be able to assess
Geographic patterns of birth outcomes or
pregnancy complications because putting
up the hospital in place of a home
address as suggested and that part of
the bill is inaccurate this will be
especially problematic for both
high-risk pregnancies and deliveries
among rural residents but also the
problem is specific to my community
Public Health agencies or researchers
will be unable to assess clusters of
birth defects or other health impacts
things like birth weight or preeclampsia
or on newborns because we will not have
town of residence or maternal age age is
necessary for all analysis of this kind
because newborn health problems are
strongly tied to maternal age in
Merrimack we have a pfas exposure
contamination problem and one of the
known Associated Health outcomes is low
birth weight in newborns without the
ability to assess whether in a hospital
we may know that these children are
being born with low birth weight but we
won't be able to tie them to Merrimack
essentially this would give a free pass
to a polluter like psychobane and other
polluters because the de-identification
of birth data will make those analysis
impossible so it's just another thought
another perspective on how this will
potentially impact not only you know a
piece situation but other environmental
impacts that DHHS may wish to Monitor
and they'll be thwarted in that process
so that's all thank you thank you for
your testimony
cocaine uh Heidi and Sam Caswell
good afternoon Madam chair Maguire and
members of the committee my name is
Heidi Caswell and I reside in Bedford
New Hampshire I'm here with my son Sam
Caswell today
and I'm here to testify against Senate
Bill 105 in the enormous impact it will
have on the timeliness of notifying
providers of out of range results for
babies born with life-threatening
diseases
diagnosis via newborn screening offers
the earliest treatment for a number of
diseases some in which a delay of only a
few days can be the difference between
life and death in many cases later
treatment will limit optimal results
that could have otherwise slowed or even
stopped progression of a deadly disease
I had a small pot in advocating for mps1
to be added to the newborn screening my
son and I both spoke at the newborn
screening meeting the night that mps1
xald and pompe disease were being voted
on to be added and we were thrilled when
they were
I was and continue to be invested on a
very personal level you see my son Sam
was born with mps1 hurler syndrome
the most severe type of mps1 and I had
to fight long and hard for a diagnosis
I don't want any other parent to have to
wait for answers like I did when early
diagnosis is right at our fingertips
today
back in 1997
when Sam was diagnosed
there weren't any doctors that seemed to
know what MPS was and still there were
very few today that do I think they
study it for 10 minutes in medical
school so they don't see the signs
and newborn screening didn't exist for
Sam's disease and so many others back
when he was born and a lot of hard work
has gone into making this a reality by
not providing the infant's name I
believe the bill will send us into a
tailspin backwards
after all the progress that's been made
to identify serious medical conditions
at Birth that were previously so
difficult to diagnose
mps1 like many other diseases on the
panel progresses quickly but there are
often not physical signs until it is too
late for the healthiest outcome both
physically and cognitively the Damage
that has taken place prior to treatment
is irreversible which is why it is
imperative the diagnosis be made is
shortly after birth as possible
newborn screening saves lives by giving
babies born with life-threatening
conditions early treatment that can slow
down or even stop the progression of an
otherwise deadly disease
parents have hope where there was none
before
they get to see their children grow up
I'm so thankful to have my son Sam
sitting next to me today because I very
easily could have lost him like so many
of my MPS friends have lost their
children
My Hope Is that the Department of Vital
Records in the Department of Health and
Human Services can work together to
revise the worksheet to accommodate the
Privacy Factor while not negatively
impacting the records in surveillance of
newborn screening
I'll close by reiterating the statement
I believe encompasses the essence of
this bill the timeliness of out of range
results on the newborn screening panel
will be greatly impacted which will
interfere with the purpose of the test
which was to identify and treat diseases
that would have progressed or even worse
resulted in unnecessary Death newborn
screening does save lives as I was ready
to leave the house this morning
I had a notification and I went on to my
Facebook page and it was kind of
um surreal that this post came up and
this is a friend of mine who lives in
Michigan who's lost two children to mps1
her post read happy birthday in heaven
Matthew today it's hard to believe you
were 37 years old on my way to work this
morning I wished you a happy birthday
and then I said I know you're with your
sister his sister also died of mps1 I
only got to spend three birthdays with
you but in my heart you were never
forgotten love you my dear son until I
see you again happy birthday no parent
should have to be wishing their children
a happy birthday in heaven when they can
be diagnosed through newborn screening
obviously it didn't exist back then but
it does now so I think we really have to
take it seriously
thank you for your time
thank you very much
dear chair Maguire and members of the
committee my name is Sam Caswell and I'd
like to thank you for letting me share a
few words today about why newborn
screening is important to me if newborn
screening have been available for my
disease when I was born I would have
been diagnosed within days after birth
and my life would be very different
I feel extremely lucky and thankful to
be here but sadly a number of MPS
friends I have met over the years are
not when you have mps1 there is a
deficiency of a particular enzyme or in
most cases you are completely missing
the enzyme which is necessary in order
for the body to break down and recycle
materials and cells
without it waste materials store in
every organ and tissue causing death
without early treatment the reason early
diagnosis is so important is because the
damage taking place to organs every day
can never be reversed
treatment will prevent further organ
damage but you can never get rid of what
is already accumulated
now that mps1 is on a newborn screening
panel the lack of enzyme activity is
flagged and the baby is able to be
tested for mps1 and get immediate
treatment
I was so excited when my disease was
added to the panel because I figured
these babies wouldn't have to go through
a lot of what I have
I didn't get treatment to give me the
enzyme for a year which was the case
where a lot of my friends with MPS and
it damaged to the cells and major organs
during that time causes a lifetime of
damage
my lungs and heart valves have been
greatly affected and a number of my
friends when MPS have died from these
issues
I was mainstream for school but the work
didn't come to me as easily as it did
for my peers and a lot of the kids I
know were in life skills programs
because of getting treatment later
being detected from newborn screening
and getting early treatment improves
quality of life in every way
it slows down the progression of the
disease and prevents permanent tissue
and organ damage if I had been able to
get the enzyme shortly after birth I
would be leading a very different and
much more independent life than I am
I really hope the babies of the future
when MPS continue to have opportunities
I haven't by being diagnosed for newborn
screening thank you for your time
thank you thank you for your testimony
Mr Caswell
are there any questions
I don't see any
thank you
uh I'm going to ask the lobbyists then
the agencies to support the subcommittee
as necessary
uh
this is getting a bit
a bit repetitive and I think the
subcommittee can work out some of the
details
is there any member of the public that
wishes to speak on Senate Bill 105 and
is there anyone in support of Senate
bill 105.
please we will be delighted to take your
written testimony at any time
all right in that case I'm going to
close this public hearing
the subcommittee will this bill will go
to representative groda's subcommittee
and we will be working on it
Madam chair yes yes I think you'll agree
with me um I'd like to thank all of the
families who came and gave their
personal stories today thank you very
much for taking the time to come before
us yes
Madam chair yes I'd like to also thank
all of the various bureaus and agencies
because the complexity between Vital
Records DHHS the way this process
happens it was really important for us
to hear how complex people who thought
this was going to be simple were very
mistaken thank you
well said representative Gould all right
we are
going to take a break
and
I'd like the Republicans to come back as
soon as possible so we can have a brief
caucus prior to our executive session
you'll need to get copies of that okay
okay welcome back everybody
we hope everyone has a chance to calm
down and eat something
all right so we are an executive session
and Senate Bill 108 that we heard this
morning is going to be added to the list
yes that's the uh public defenders
okay
so I'm going to start with the bills
that I know have committee reports
already written
so representative shuitt you have a
motion on Senate bill 147.
microphone
I move that we adopt Amendment 1493.
all right I'll second that if you're
okay
it's going to say there's no one going
to second man is that 14
Amendment 1493-1493
all right
you can you can talk about that while
you're uh while we're all sleeping
through our papers to find it yeah
everyone should have a copy
and passed it out just before we broke
okay and
basically
um
amends the Senate amended version
to
strike out what the senate had
originally put in which is addressing
you're not we're not you're not
projecting properly
sorry I moved it back because I was
pulling through my papers
[Laughter]
um the major difference is
under on page two
of the build if you're looking at the
bill
under age
and
I'm sorry I am looking at the amendment
looking at the amendment on page two
line 20 through 22.
we struck the Senate Amendment
originally took that entire exemption
out but we reinstated it to say that the
board can exempt the dentist one
specific dentist
from the above requirement if they are
board eligible or were certified in
either Dental anesthesiology or oral and
maxillofacial surgery we heard
in the subcommittee and subsequently
that this was something that the board
was seeking to do
and the rest of the amendment is
basically just
allowing the board to Institute rules
to facilitate
the changes that were brought in the
Senate amended version of the bill
yes and the
the audit of the Dental Board identified
that a they should have a a subcommittee
on anesthesiology
anesthesiologists to
provide technical expertise and so
that's what the bill does
in the amendment and they also took
umbrage with the idea that all board
certified dentists would be exempt from
the requirement of having a second
person there
so this only allows them to exempt
specific people or specific
circumstances and
I'm okay with with allowing the board to
have the authority to do that and
they're already working on rules that
would implement it
and the other important part in the bill
that came from the Senate was to permit
Dental facilities because that had not
been addressed previously in the
statutes
and it came up at caucus and I'd like to
reiterate that it's very different from
the facility licensing for massage
parlors because the Dental Board already
inspects dental offices and facilities
for suitability for for anesthesia
what this does is it allows them to give
the license
for the facility at one time and they
don't have to repeat the application and
the inspection
every time Personnel changes so it's
it's simpler
are there any other comments or
questions
okay
not seeing any the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1493.
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative santon estazo yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative abar yes
representative Gerhart yes the clerk
votes yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative grassview yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
president Smith
yes and the chair yes the uh vote is 19
to zero
okay
representative shuitt
I'll move ought to pass with the
amendment on Centerville 147.
I'll second
um do you wish to discuss I don't think
there's too much more to be said about
the bill we've pretty much discussed the
whole thing
what she said anyone wish to make a
comment question
all right seeing none in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 147 the clerk and call
the roll
okay representative Simon yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Samson yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative abar yes
representative Gerhart yeah
clerk votes yes representative Schmidt
yes representative goalie yes
representative
yes representative of Brian yeah
I wrote yes sorry representative Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative is
um representative Gould yes and
representative Smith
yes and the chair yes um you forgot me
yeah
someone forgotten
oh grassy I am so sorry
yeah
another another demerit
do you what did you vote
okay
it's 19 to zero all right and the motion
passes 19 to zero is there any objection
to consent
all right seeing none we'll put that one
on consent
okay and the next one is
uh
Senate Bill 203 yes
representative shua do you want to move
the commotion
I can't find it
did you have an amendment what's the
number
um so I believe we are looking at
Amendment one three six five
so you're moving the amendment and this
was
um adopted by the subcommittee in a
three to nothing vote
and basically it um
it negates the rest of the bill
because the inclination
one we heard from the Commerce Committee
which normally would hear this
representative do we have that Amendment
pardon me do we have that amendment I
can't find it
I think I believe that she submitted
this it was days ago yeah at the last
the last time we got together yeah which
let me see if I can so it's somewhere in
your files
and somewhere in my files which I can't
find either
I can almost read it to you it's only
like two sentences why don't you do that
while we're all shuffling papers here
okay please do read it representation
uh I'm in the bill by replacing all
after the enacting Clause with the
following office of professional life
insurance certification board of
manufactured housing website if the
board excuse me if the board of
manufactured housing under RSA 205 a
colon 25 through colon 31 is repealed
then the office of professional
licensure and certification shall
maintain the board of manufactured
housing website for the board for a
minimum of five years from the effective
date of this act which is 60 days after
Passage
that's because the board is actually
abolished in-house Bill 2
and if that goes through
we are
what's the word I want to use expecting
that there's likely going to be some
sort of reiteration of a board to deal
with the issues that as we heard are
very prevalent
and this would allow
that word to be referenced through the
ovalc website at some point
if it happens in five years if it
doesn't happen that soon then they
probably don't need one yeah the
testimony at the hearing convinced me
that we did not want to
maintain the board and change it in the
way the bill wanted
but
it does it does serve a useful purpose
we aren't really the right people to
figure out how to get a
quasi-judicial complaint board set up
but we can at least save the history and
the records so that whenever such such
any an organ
whatever method is chosen to deal with
the issue they won't lose the history I
thought that would be important and the
oplc says it doesn't cost anything so
let's do it okay
I need for representative true
and but
um I'm still shuffling
so
the website that is maintained is the
oplc it for some reason because its
title is board the and nobody else
wanted it the manufactured housing board
which is a quasi-nuditional board to
resolve issues in manufactured housing
parks
is housed within the oplc
and their website is on the oplc website
there's a link to it
so they'll keep it
that is Senate Bill 203 Amendment 1365.
do we have any
idea what the Senate's going to do in
response
I mean we may not care but
uh the thing of it is that the house
position is that board goes away
so it's in hb2 all right good enough so
if it's going away
we certainly don't want to reinstate it
and reformulate it
and we don't know what the Senate is
going to do because it's in house two
which they haven't yet produced
they're still thinking about
it
awesome
it keeps the history
any other questions
okay not seeing any the motion is to
adopt Amendment 1365 that the clerk and
call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastazo yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bar yes
representative Gerhart yes
clerk votes yes representative Schmidt
yes representative goalie yes
representatives to it yes representative
Horrigan yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith
yes and the chair yes 19 to zero the
amendment passes
I move ought to pass with Amendment for
Senate bill 203.
seconds all over
I think Gould was first yes
um and I'll just say that uh
we've covered everything I think
and uh represent Gould do you have a
comment I'll say the same and certainly
the ROC community members are I think
are going to be very happy with this
okay well we hope so that's
well it's
yeah we'll
yes
we're not going to oppose that
particular board on them
any other comments
okay the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on Senate Bill 203
and the clerk can call the rule okay
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastazo yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a Barr yes
representative Gerhart yes the clerk
votes yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes representative Horrigan yes
representative Grassfield yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes
okay 19 to zero all right any objections
to consent
seeing none will put that one on consent
also
Okay so
is there anyone else who has a
pre-written committee report that we can
deal with
seeing none will go on to more of the
easy ones
Senate Bill 108 which we heard this
morning
does anyone have emotion we said we'd
try an execut this afternoon
all right representative Gould moves
ought to pass and second by
representative Simon Patrick oh excuse
me for Patrick I could tell which
direction it was coming
okay representative Gould do you wish to
to speak to your motion
well obviously I was very moved by the
testimony this morning because of their
work with Juvenile Justice Defenders but
seriously I think that this is an
important means to help them retain and
recruit good quality public defenders
the service they provide to our state 80
percent I was shocked at that number of
um
of the cases in New Hampshire they
represent and
um and they just do a fantastic job and
so I'm very supportive of this all right
representative Fitzpatrick
representative Goods summed it up just
fine thank you thank you representative
just briefly I mean I express concerns
about the cost but that was based on a
a incorrect assumption that
they weren't getting subsidized health
care now and this would be adding it
which could be a significant expense but
apparently they're getting it now this
will just be a different program and it
will be minor changes so I'm okay with
it okay I
yes they give us some some data to show
the insurance convince us that the it
was a better deal
anyone else have a comment question
because the motion is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 108 and the clerk can call
the rule representative Simon yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nastazo
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a Barr yes representative Gerhart yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuette yes
representative Oregon yes representative
grassy yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes
19 to 0 the bill passes all right any
objections to consent
okay representative Gould we're going to
want that committee report
uh before you leave today
okay
and
Senate bill 53.
the subcommittee has met has agreed but
they don't want us to pass the bill
to act on the bill until after the
building code review board has met so we
will
pick that up on our next scheduled
executive session which is Wednesday the
20th 24th I think or 25th
of May
when
the 24th okay May 20th yes it is okay
May 24th we are going to have an
executive session for anything that's
still in subcommittee or that we don't
finish today and especially including
Senate bill 53.
no today was the last hearing
thank you
if I oh okay
all right
moving on to Senate Bill 49 which is the
only Bill we have to vote on today uh
representative goalie I believe you have
a motion
thank you madam chair I uh have an
amendment to offer
on Senate bill 49.
your amendment is
1476h that I handed out just prior to
the exact session
and I know everybody has a stack of
papers in front of them so
and I'll second that
1476. all right you wish to speak to
your motion sure this um
was brought forward
um because I feel and I think listening
to the majority of the folks here on the
Edna committee feel that
um
appropriate that
oplc have a dedicated lapsing fund
non-lapsing fund
um of up to three million dollars but
once it gets to that 3 million the bill
is I came over
sent any surplus over 3 million back to
the general fund I think it's important
that that money be used to reduce
licensing fees and certification instead
of just filling the coffers of the
general fund um this is what that is
intended for and this is what that this
amendment does is keeps that money
towards fee reductions
are you making that motion
representative goalie oh yep second
thank you representative Schmidt okay
if you wish to speak to your second
okay anyone else have a comment the
question representative true and then
Simon
um I offer my sincere congratulations to
the representative in the corner
my objections I I thought we were over
taxing
uh for money just to go into the general
fund
um and that would have been a no for me
um
limiting it to 3 million I know the uh
they had a problem with uh money running
out all the all the money going back to
the general fund and I'm not having any
money to run
let me get it to three million seems
fair to me
representative Simon thank you madam
chair yeah um I'm in support of this I
just wanted to make a mention of uh I'm
assuming that the oplc will be in charge
of redistributing Licensing fees and
certification fees under this uh my only
concern and just for the record and for
the record only
um
is just redistribution of one board's
fees to other boards I like it way
better than sending it to the general
fund but I'd love to know how oplc is
going to do that in there
we are all interested
and
I think if you look down to line 15 that
the office of professional licensure and
certification show report biannually
each July on how the funds were expended
over the previous biennium so hopefully
in that reporting we will find out where
the money is going they are also
required by it by other statute that the
um
they report annually to that same list
of people
on all of their boards what they've done
and it includes things like how many
people are licensed under each board how
many complaints and what the fees are
and you and it's very easy to look at
that and say this Board needs to
is paying too much and this board is
probably paying isn't paying enough so I
think that's uh
we should be able to adjust how they're
other expending it representative Simon
yeah my only other thought too is maybe
we can communicate with oplc although I
know they know this is a concern as well
um keeping those fees consistent from
year to year so that the licensees know
when there's a drop because of excess
funds and to expect it to go back up the
next year
um you know so that they have an
anticipation of what what what's coming
down the pike yes
I'm sure it's going to be interesting to
see how they adjust just the fees
all right
any further comments
those in uh the Motions adopt Amendment
1476 and the clerk can pull the rule
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey
[Music]
yes
representative Sanchez yes
representative true yes Christina Dolan
yes representative abar yes
representative Gerhart yes represent the
other clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Grassi yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes representative Smith yes and the
chair yes
1920 the amendment is adopted all right
represent
I move ought to pass with them in second
okay
we assume discuss it add anything to the
previous discussion
no way representative Schmidt
I'm good thanks okay anyone else have a
question comment concern
producer
these are all replace all amendments
make it easy
uh so the motion is is to
ought to pass on Senate Bill 49 with
Amendment 1476 and the clerk can call
the role representative Simon yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Senator
nostrazo yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a Barr yes representative Gearhart yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt
aye representative goalie yes
representative
we representative Horrigan yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould uh-huh
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes
19-0 on a pass but the amendment is
adopted all right motion passes 19-0 and
the objection to consent
okay
and for the record I am reliably
informed by a knowledgeable sources that
uh-huh is actually comes from the
Abenaki word or yes
yes thank you representative yes thank
you so that's why we get it backwards
all right Senate Bill 71 representative
Simon you've got a an amendment yes
Madam chair I move Amendment 1521h
speak to your motion um sure so
um the bill as it came to us had two
parts to it the first um expanded the
presumption that cancer disease in a
firefighter was occupationally
um had occurred occupationally
um
and so for the purposes of
workers compensation uh would be
presumed that that cancer was caused uh
while on the job and the second part uh
formed a commission uh to study a
screening for firefighters
um this amendment keeps the first part
of the bill intact and Strikes the
commission the members of the
subcommittee
um were agreed that the commission was
likely to be ineffective in reaching the
goals uh that it wanted to achieve and
so we took that out
okay
you have something
who did second that true represent true
do we should speak to your second
yes just uh to to clarify a little bit
that what we did in the subcommittee
um
this this this makes it a presumption
that and that cancer uh on a within a
firefighter
um is uh workman's compensated workman's
comp I would be a workman's comp case
that that presumption as it was
explained
does not mean a guaranteed coverage
they gave an example of a case that was
undercover that was being covered as the
bill as the law is now
and it went before workman's
compensation they argued the point and
the uh the case was denied even though
that particular cancer was one that came
under the presumption
um so knowing that the presumption is
not an automatic guarantee of workman's
compensation it still has to be proven
Beyond a reasonable sense of Doubt
um I I came to the conclusion that this
is this amendment should pass
okay
representative leckis and then shewitt
uh just uh glad to see that the
amendment fixes the problem of a
committee which is formed its report is
due and it's ended on the same day
yes that was a special case
do you have a question yes I thought we
had talked about eliminating the Cancer
Society from the membership oh yes well
let's if we're deleting the commission
it doesn't uh matter okay this is
deleting okay all right all right the
if I may the point is that this
information is needed but
in a short period of time that
that study commission was just
infeasible right so we hope that uh very
the insurance company or workers comp or
the employers of firemen
will do some studies
okay
we think we just don't think that one is
going to work
okay
any other comments or questions
sure
but but fun
um
another problem with the bill as it was
written
is that in any committee or Commission
the legislature must form a majority of
the committee
and and the bill as it was written we
were the minority
and that is is for future reference
we'll probably never hear of a committee
or a commission again in this
in this committee but uh
the how the legislature must form the
majority of a committee
okay
and at a technical study like that I
don't think there'd be very many
legislators who would usefully
contribute to the study
all right can anyone else have a quick
comment question
okay the motion is to adopt Amendment
1521 to Senate Bill 71 and the clerk can
call the rule a representative Simon yes
representative yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastazo yes
representative true yes representative
Dillon yes representative a bar yes
representative gerhardt yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes
the count is 19 to zero to adopt the
amendment
all right so representative Simon yes
having adopted the amendment I move SB
ought to pass as amended
any further discussion or comment
seeing none the
the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative two yes representative
doing yes representative a Barr yes
representative Gerhart
the clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative schuette yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Grassi yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes representative Smith yes and the
chair
yes 19 to zero otpa is adopted all right
the any objections to consent the motion
passed
okay we'll put that one on consent
and
all right Senate Bill 44
uh representative Grody you have emotion
I do um
let me just see if I can find it oh yes
I would like to move
um Amendment 1453
is there a second
second by representative true
okay
yes this one is
um so this amendment
um was brought to the subcommittee this
morning
and um
the
amendment is very similar to the bill
except for on the back
um well it's on the back of this bill
but it removes the criminal justice
um
degree from the
from the
requirements and um
because originally it had been put into
this bill it's not in current statute
and had been put in because
um one of the local colleges was going
to offer a course that was going to be
acceptable by the board but they have
withdrawn that the course and if there
it evolved it involved criminal justice
so any kind of um
we did clear with the director of oplc
that should there be a
um a college course
or college program that allows criminal
justice to have these kinds of courses
that are required for this kind of
practice it can be added during
rulemaking
so this what this what this amendment
does essentially does the same thing as
the original bill was to allow
individuals who are being treated and
followed by members of the laidac board
continue to
um be treated by those specialists
even though their substance abuse might
be
um
control controlled yes let's use that
word
because typically if someone who sees
the laidac specialist has their cons
their substance abuse control under
control their substitutes under control
they are then required to go seek
counseling from another
a type of best specialist so therefore
this allows continuity of care
for those individuals
anyone else
representative blackis yeah um there's
people might notice there's some change
in the wording for the education
requirements but uh
it has no real change just changes the
language that's used the requirements
are basically the same
I'd like to thank what what it also does
is that it increases the number of
mental health professionals of the state
simply by allowing them Master's level
to latex
to treat
non-coccurring disorders so I think
that's that's important
yes I'll just note also that we heard
during testimony that in many cases it
was very important for the client to
continue a relationship that they had
developed with a counselor so I think
that's an important facet
okay
anyone else
okay so the motion is to adopt Amendment
1453 to Senate Bill 44 and the clerk and
call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a Barr yes
representative Gerhard yes the clerk
votes yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative Horrigan
yes representative Grassi yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes and the chair
yes it adoption the amendment is adopted
19 to zero
okay
uh representative leckis do you have a
motion
yes
otpa on Senate Bill 44 with with the
amendment
well second second okay
do we just speak to your motion
I think we covered most of it it
increases the scope of practice for the
mldacs it allows as was mentioned
continuity of care I mean it's hard
enough for somebody to find a mental
health counselor that they work well
with to have to have them you know once
they've dealt with one problem now they
have to go find somebody else's
I think not reasonable
um that's basically what it does
all right and
any other comments
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
as amended by rep
you're correct representative Schmidt I
forgot with Amendment on Senate bill 44.
okay representative Simon yes
representative yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative abar yes
representative Gerhard yes the clerk
votes yes representative Smith Schmidt
yes both of us
representative goalie yes representative
Stewart
representative Horrigan yes
okie dokie representative grassy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould
yes representative Smith yes then the
chair yes
the
otpa is adopted 19 to zero is there any
objection to consent
seeing none we'll uh put this one on
consent also
and
moving right along Senate Bill 149
representative Brodus
chair I'd like to move
Amendment
1463 h
okay
is there a second I'll second second by
representative blackis
in this um there were two changes made
to the bill number one it references a
different RSA
um the original RSA that was referenced
in the bill
in the original bill
um was referring to the nursing board
and this is actually a nursing agency
registration it is nothing to do it is
not related to the nursing board and
therefore
we're giving it its own individual
chapter in RSA which is 326m as
recommended by oplc
the other change is
in the back
yes in a sec on on page two line six
uh on until line eight
um
this sentence ended with four such
reason which didn't really have anything
there were no reasons given in that
section so that was eliminated so the
sentence reads nurse agency shall not
commit Services of a single nurse or
licensed nursing assistant to more than
one Health Care Facility for the same
time period or a shift and cancel
commitment to a facility or compel that
facility to bid again for services
already promised it period
those are the changes that were made to
the
bill okay president oblakis thank you
um all say is uh you know even if people
have a problem with the underlying bill
I suggest supporting the amendment
because if it were to pass
without this it would get stuck under
the nursing board statute and that would
make no sense
as well as the grammar fix
thank you um was there any talk in the
subcommittee I'm just curious
um
about whether or not this section 6
through 8 on page two will delay nursing
agencies from committing to one facility
is that on the amendment yeah on the
amendment it's also on the original bill
right now I was just curious if
if they're not not allowed to basically
make somebody bid for a contract that
they already have because they're doing
that last moment presently if they'll
delay committing to one group
until
right up until the last minute I don't
we didn't hear anything specific on that
um I'll say is that
apparently other states have much more
onerous
uh bills that even have things like
price controls which I would never
support and but they are apparently able
to
staff so I would not expect that this
would cause that much of a problem
other questions or comments on the
amendment
representative Gerhard thank you on page
two line
12. just when it says they would not be
able to charge a higher rate unless
there's a
state or local Declaration of a public
health emergency who at the local level
what does that mean exactly
oh local level if you're
I don't know if the localities have an
opportunity to declare a state of
emergency they do they can oh okay I
think I think for example they they said
there's measles running around Hampton
and
so that uh which is a communicable virus
and they that would apply follow-up
I just wonder if that's an end run
around the idea of keeping rates down so
for instance let's say a town wants to
declare a public health emergency that
they can't find people to nurse man the
nursing home no okay so if I can comment
please I mean there's nothing in this
bill that prevents them from charging
anything they want separate from the
issue of a bump for an infectious
disease so
if they if if they're they want to if
the you know the best one out there is
offering an extremely high rate then
um you know that can happen and they
don't have to use the uh infectious
disease is an excuse
it just eliminates that one reason for
for uh for a temp for a spike in prices
you have to negotiate your exorbitant
rate in advance and if your concern is
that
the public health emergency would be
used to
allow it
I don't see how the local
um
Board of Health or whatever it is would
have an incentive to do that right I
mean it wouldn't be in their benefit to
do it and so I I really don't expect
that to happen you'd have to have a
nursing home in that Community right and
why would that don't work I don't see
how it could be in the interest of the
local public health people would be the
Opposites I mean I can't see them doing
it for that reason okay representative
FYI most towns
do have a public health officer which is
often in small smaller towns often
double duty of the fire chief and that's
that's who can declare them no
they might or the one of the Selectmen
gets tagged with it
all right anyone else have a comment
concern representative Gould I just will
add that you would have to have the
local officials in cahoots with the
nursing like it would have to be a major
conspiracy
well they could but but as but as
representative leckis pointed out it's
not to the benefit of the local official
to let the agency charge more to their
local nursing home or whatever
all right
any other comments
okay the motion is to adopt Amendment
1463.
and the clerk and call the rules
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastazo yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yeah representative abar yes
representative Gerhard yes the clerk
votes yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
yes representative Horrigan yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair yes
the amendment is adopted 19 to zero okay
representative
I move auto pass on House Bill
I mean out a pass with Amendment on
House Bill 149.
Senate bill Senate Bill 149 excuse me
second by representative Gould
is there
do you wish to speak to your motion
right so this bill came to us because of
concerns by the health care agencies
that their staff was being
um sent to the highest bidder
which makes it very difficult for people
to control their health care and um
therefore this bill does really
um a few things number one it allows for
a nurse agency registration in the state
so therefore these in these companies
that are
providing nurse agencies to the state
um are on record
the other is that it does not allow them
to if they've committed to a nursing
facility
they can't
um remove that assist that that nurse to
another facility
because the other facility has outbid
the current facility
and also importantly the nursing
agencies cannot place
and license individuals with a license
that has been suspended
so these are all things that I think um
help a local nursing facilities and
which should help at least keep track of
the rising costs of
care in the in our state
yeah I mean I'll make an argument for it
that's slightly different I don't have a
problem with things going to the highest
bidder the way to solve that is get more
Supply however
what they're apparently doing is coming
to an agreement on a price for a nurse
and then at the last minute saying oh
well we have a better offer somewhere
else and that's
you know at best sleazy in an ethical
business practices and it may actually
be a violation of their contract and we
we asked you know during the
subcommittee about
you know remedies for that you know if
it is a violation the contract could go
to the attorney general and what we
heard is that really nothing happens
it's not effective
um and it's largely for that reason I
was willing to support this
um and I mean the part about
you know say placing nurses with
suspended license I mean that's illegal
already it's just the nursing agency can
be on the hook for doing it
and I I asked about enforcement because
we do things that there's no way to
enforce it it's pointless um
and we were told that
you know that that
oplc can can talk to them about a go
after them but
ultimately they could either be fined or
prohibited from Contracting in the state
and so that would act as a pretty strong
disincentive
for this kind of thing
and the deal about prohibiting
the up charge for infectious diseases
I don't I mean I kind of prefer that
wasn't in there and in general I prefer
that this was handled through contract
and and consumer protection stuff but
apparently that isn't working
I don't think the upcharge thing is
that significant because I mean there
they were doing it again at the last
minute which is not the way to do
business
there's also a Prohibition against
recruiting on the grounds of the
facility
and I think that's
I think you know almost meaningless to
get a hold of somebody in other
circumstances so I don't care too much
about that but it's basically I think uh
bad business practices and possibly
contract violations while I was willing
to support it
okay well I mean the thing is the
reality is that none of this may be
effective in preventing this situation
it does give some kind of possibility of
slowing inhibiting it or sanctioning it
after the fact but it's better than
doing nothing
yeah just briefly I mean this is not
going to fix the underlying problem of
um you know facilities having to pay a
huge amount of money to get nurses uh to
to cover when people leave or away for
some reason the only solution of that
long term is to increase the supply and
whatever we can do to help that that we
haven't done we should but it it'll
hopefully stop some pretty egregious
business practices
yes representative Gerhart
yeah it's just following up on rep
representative lekkas's comments on the
recruitment of potential employees on
the premise of the healthcare facility
it just seems very vague and I think it
could use the justification for firing
employees that
whatever reason it just seems like it's
an unprovable thing either way there's
no enforcement mechanism but can still
use justification for harassing someone
or whatever if you really want to stop
that then we just have them all wear
body cameras or something I mean well
it's just it gets into this very weird
big brother-esque kind of thing that's
my opinion thank you yes I I think that
the main thing it will do is prevent the
agency from posting on the employees
bulletin board you know want more
you know you you can't stop people
talking to each other and I'm sure the
the nurses will talk to the uh the
agents
the world will get around the other
thing is I mean I can't I mean the
facilities problem is they can't recruit
and retain enough nurses I don't see
that they would be using the fact that
somebody who works there talked to one
of the contracted nurses about a job as
a reason to fire them because their
problem is they don't want them to leave
so I I just don't see it as a real
problem so
okay
representative true
thank you madam chair
I I like to believe that I always have a
problem when we pass a law that's
unenforceable
um
and so like in the situation where
you're not allowed to talk to other
employees
I don't see how that's
enforceable at all
uh nor do I see a nursing home wanting
to enforce that
as far as
the nursing the nurse agency should not
commit to Services of a single nurse etc
etc that's on uh second page two of the
Amendments line six
what I heard in testimony is
I believe it was the director of a
nursing home maybe Hillsborough I'm not
sure that he would get between a rock
and a hard place and it'd have somebody
lined up
to work and they needed that body there
to make the ratios of
of employees to to patients
and at the last minute
that nursing agency XYZ pulls the leg up
Monday and he has to pay extra money to
go to nursing home a nursing agency X
but he has no way of punishing the
agency that that did that to him
because he needs them maybe next week
on on the amendment
on page page one line 29
uh
the director May revoke
right
um I don't know if that's going to
happen I don't know if that's going to
be another
unenforced rule
because of the shortage and that's
that's the whole problem of all this
because we have a shortage I I get I
don't think that's going to be a mole
hill that I'm going to die on but
it just seems uh unenfossible
thank you
anyone else
I'd have to say I I kind of agree except
that I would imagine that the
director of oplc would have more clout
with the attorney general saying well
here I've got 17 verified complaints
against this one agency
than you know each agency each nursing
home calling in once and saying you know
they they screwed me that's a that's the
only way I think it's likely to get more
enforced is if we can consolidate the
complaints and then sick the AG on them
because
that'll that would make it more likely
that something might happen
but
anyone else
all right
in that case of motion it is ought to
pass with Amendment on Senate Bill 149
and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
blackis yes representative Bailey no
representative sentence no
representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bar yes representative Gearhart no
the clerk votes yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie
yes representative Stewart yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative grassy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes and the chair
no
okay it is 15 to 4.
the amendment the otpa passes and will
there be a Minority Report
or sorry
that's okay you're practicing
uh I'm not going to write one
it can't go on the consent right it's
not going on no no I object to putting
it on not before
all right okay so representative santa
nastasso wants to write a Minority
Report all right that
okay we have not yet doubled up anybody
so
the last bill synonym for you
okay
and
Senate Bill 207
I had an amendment which was I didn't
pick one up myself but I put it out
there which deleted
I I moved that Amendment whatever number
it is is there a second
well I don't know what the amendment
says we don't let me let me go get the
amendment okay I put a stack of them out
there
getting signals in here
okay
it's right here oh okay sorry about that
yeah Senate bill to us
oh good
all right
thank you
okay
so representative Simon has seconded my
motion
and
what this amendment does is
simply delete the study committee on
licensure mental health professionals
since we're doing that all over the
place in subcommittees and retain bills
so I don't want to create a formal
committee
but we didn't get much testimony about
the medical and Trauma services
so I thought we should at least discuss
it and see if it's important
I have nothing else to say
representative Simon
I have nothing to add thank you
does anyone know anything about the peer
support groups
or remember any testimony about it
okay representative Gould
please
sorry I know a little bit about him it's
sort of anecdotal information as a
uh I know a family member is a client
and then a friend is a staff so
um
all I can tell you is it's a it's an
important and emerging I think aspect to
Mental Health Services by allowing uh
people who are doing well in their life
but who have had experience and
understanding to be able to be employed
to assist and I can give you an example
the peer support people were being
called upon when we had
um a crate I think it was about four
weeks ago there was a crazy amount of
um actively psychotic people being
warehoused in the Concord Hospital and
so they had actively people in active
psychosis strapped on gurneys sitting
around in the halls and so this peer
support group was able to be called upon
to come in to help
um assist with with keeping the clients
calm until
something better could be figured out
but anyway so those are the kind of
services that they provide
all right I'm thank you for
representative blackis yeah my
understanding I mean I I think I was out
sick today this had a hearing although I
guess there wasn't much presented but in
looking it over I'm not sure it would
apply in that case it seems to be
support of um
other
employees as opposed to
patients in the hospital setting like
that
my question is assuming that's correct
I mean there's no money for this so is
there
anything right now that would prohibit
let's say a fire department or a police
department or
anything like anything like that or
their unions from organizing this right
now I mean is there really
a need for this and and how does this do
more than what they can do right now
yeah I I thank you rep I tend to agree
with you I don't know what it does
represent Gould thank you I'm sorry I
I'm trying to write my report for you
before the end of the day and wasn't
paying super close attention so this
kind of support group is for
um we heard testimony remember uh
about the all the trauma that the police
and and other First Responders are are
serving so
um that's what this is in reference to
but it's the same kind of concept as
what I was talking about it's well we we
okay are you do you have information on
this could you please
uh the the testimony at the hearing was
um I can't remember any of it
good afternoon for the record my name is
John McAllister I'm secretary treasurer
for the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire
and um I hope I can maybe help answer
some of the questions that the committee
may have
okay
um I remember
representative Prue was on something
like this where they dealt with First
Responders who had been in traumatic
situations correct and in um the
organization that representative approve
belongs to is a critical incident stress
debriefing team so after a critical
incident that a fire department or
police department May deal with they
call this team in and they have the um
the team counsel the members that were
involved with that directly as far as
peer support groups which the
professional firefighters in New
Hampshire we have our own peer support
team uh the International Association of
firefighters which is the organization
that we belong to we they have
established a peer support program and
the peers support the the idea of the
peer support teams is is a one-on-one
period peer-to-peer counseling
so they will send our indiv our members
to a class it's a um a couple day long
class where we will learn how to deal
with
peer support one on one
um and it's basically firefight in our
situation it's firefighters helping
other firefighters
authority to do that because if I if I
understand it the current loss talks
about
it's vertical incident stress management
team is
one or more trained volunteers including
members of peer support groups
um
so it sounds to me like
you can do this already well
excuse me
so under the current RSA the the
individual peer support teams are not
covered and that the
and I believe that's what
for the
you mean they're not they're not
codified is that what you mean
I'm sorry what was that representative
I'm over here I'm sorry they're not it's
not they're not codified or defined
correct
if I could help please
so when um
there is I appear with you
um
can be done many ways
and one of the ways that it's done
professionally in the Mental Health
Board mental health area is when you
have social workers who work for the
same practice
and they see different cases but
sometimes they need confirmation from
their fellow social workers that indeed
they're following the right course of
practice I mean doctors do this too I
mean they have case reviews where they
all sit around the table and they talk
about someone's medical condition just
to make sure that the condition that the
the the protocol that's been outlined
for that individual is the correct one
is the most likely to succeed
so when this is done on this kind of a
basis
is done with individuals for example
like firefighters it could be with
individuals who
um are handling
um an issue with the town I guess
representative
representative Maguire's Amendment
addresses this and this was in the
original Bill what her Amendment does is
eliminates the commission
and just keeps the original part of the
bill
um so I don't know why did you do that
as opposed to why did you you kept this
because because we didn't get any
testimony on it that's right and I
thought it might be important and I
figured we should at least I'm not
I'm not willing to say I'm strongly in
support of it but I'm much more in
support of this than
me okay I'm gonna can I oh sorry no
comment on that please continue okay so
I was on the study committee
and I am in support of study committee
um because um and I think that this was
brought out as a result of some of the
testimony that we had in study committee
and frankly I was more focused on the
study committee than I was on this part
so this sort of caught me by surprise
um but
uh so I
um
let me see
I'm just going to read this quickly
okay yeah I I will say that I took out
the study committee because we have
at least one retained Bill and pieces of
House Bill 2 and House Bill 655 that we
are looking at and specifically on the
licensure of mental health professionals
and I don't think we want to create a
separate study committee
but when we're already looking at that
so that's that's why I took the study
committee out I'm
didn't wasn't sure that this was useless
so I left it so representative goalie
you're more familiar with it thank you
madam chair
and
I I think if I recall correctly that the
definition of peer support group was put
in place because we all know
representative pru does this type of
work and I think this establishes what a
peer support group is and puts it puts
it into the statutes and also includes
peer support group
for providing these services to not only
our First Responders but anyone who may
need their services it just increases
the number of folks who are going to be
allowed to provide those peer support
um for those in need whether it's for
Stress Management critical incident
stress debriefing or any of that I think
this defines what his group does and
what his organization does and helps
going forward
I have a question on that and I I mean I
think the idea in doing this is great
um but you said this would allow more
people to get involved if I heard you
correctly
I mean what's preventing them without
this from doing it I don't
I would think that
any fire department any police
department and maybe other organizations
or the unions in conjunction with them
could do this kind of thing and I'm some
I'm just reluctant to put things in
statute that aren't really necessary or
that might
kind of fossilizes things in a certain
State and might reduce some flexibility
so I'm really wondering I think I had
been explanation okay okay so according
to RSA 281
Dash a colon 2.
it defines
emergency
281-a colon 2.
13 yes right
it that means it's been defined as call
volunteer call volunteer or regular
firefighters Law Enforcement Officers
certified County correction officers
emergency communication dispatchers and
rescue or ambulance workers including
Ambulance Service Medical
emergency medical personnel and first
responder service and volunteer
Personnel so that without meeting those
requirements
any other organization cannot
participate or cannot be considered this
under that RSA
is that correct as to where I am is that
correct yes that is correct and it's for
liability reasons
liability I forgot that part right so it
says the critical so
um
and then in rsa153 a
colon 17 it reads critical incidence
stress management team or team means the
group of one or more trained volunteers
including members of peer support groups
organized by a unit of State local or
country County Government
and then this is where or members of the
Union of Emergency Response
slash Public Safety workers as defined
by RSA 281 colon 2 paragraph six okay
so what this does is it it expands
expansive okay yes thank you
um
so that's why we needed that
but
I guess we're waiting on this but I
would like to I will be voting no
because I want the whole bill I want to
study Commission because being on the
city commission which meant quite we met
sick four times just to address
um
the issues that had to do with licensing
and certification of of those
individuals who are in who are working
with
um mental health care and there were
still and many of the
um
issues are going to be addressed in
House Bill oops not the house bill in
the non-germaine amendment to House Bill
as we refer to that house bill never to
be named and then
um we will um continue we want to
continue that work because we felt that
we had more information did you want to
say something
thank you thank you Representatives my
name is Marissa Chase I'm the executive
director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice euphemism for
the trial lawyers
um Senator bird so working with our
um one of our members who exclusively
does workers comp on behalf of
plaintiffs and often works with pffnh
Senator birdsold asked for help around
this language so I apologize
um Senator Birdsall had reached out to
this attorney for help with this
language and I have a note on why it's
important if that would be helpful for
the committee please
um
so if I can get my phone to cooperate
here okay
so critical incident stress management
team or team means the group of one or
more trained volunteers including
members peer support groups or members
of a union of Emergency Response Public
Safety workers as defined by RSA 281 a
colon 2vi which I believe was reflected
in Senate Bill 207 as amended not in the
original Bill there was some debate
around the language to be able to
Encompass peer support groups across the
Spectrum not just you know because
they're defined differently in different
areas of statute
the above is I think a narrow definition
definitionally limited to the classes of
First Responders already defined by the
workers compensation law and then only
to establish unions of such First
Responders this narrowly defined
expansion eliminates any Union of
non-first responders from coverage by
definition and further addresses concern
about a future expansion by avoiding
entirely a regulatory loophole of an
administrative burdens caused by any
other employee organization applying to
the safety commissioner for workers comp
covers when we talk about liability
we're talking about coverage under the
workers compensation statute making sure
these folks are eligible for workers
compensation what the language is
drafted meaning without any savings
Clause like quote or other such
organization approved within the
discretion of the safety commissioner
unquote No Union Beyond those already
blessed as First Responders by RSA 281a
can even get in the door that's why this
is so important as a reminder the
definition of Emergency Response Public
Safety workers and RSA 281-a
into
six means call volunteer or regular
firefighters Law Enforcement Officers
certified under RSA 106-l certified
County Corrections Officers emergency
communication dispatchers and rescue or
ambulance workers including Ambulance
Service emergency medical personnel
first responder service and volunteer
Personnel so I hope I clarify that and
didn't make it more confusing but the
real underlying need for this is to make
sure that these emergency peer response
groups are eligible for workers
compensation coverage when performing
their
you know a really valuable service
okay
yes representative Bailey
are we expecting something to happen to
them while they're counseling
looks like it's a very difficult
question no not and it's not a difficult
question I I guess the the
it's so much as to be covered under
liability as well not just so much
workers compensation
foreign
these are the people that can be in this
group counseling or something right so I
assume whatever's happened has happened
this is after the fact so why is there
some danger in doing this or so I think
it came up in testimony and
representative Grotto would know better
than I but I believe what happened is
some of these
um peer support services are given by
um
retired members that are not actively
part of a union
so this is making sure that they are
covered when they're engaging in peer
support services covered for what cover
for workers compensation liability
making sure that if something does
happen then
they're covered as well I see it's an
incentive mechanism to be able to get
them to engage
counseling and then there to be sued and
are we covered okay I understand thank
you okay representative Gould do you
have
have we covered your point
I think so and and I'm assuming like I
know there's a lot of reticence among
the fields I'm okay I'm a big strong guy
I don't need help or a woman and so does
any of this language and and and making
it defined and easier for peer support
People Help by codifying it are we
helping encourage departments to set up
peer support groups
are just protecting them
I believe they go hand in hand
it also protects these members on the
confidential confidentiality clause
um yeah okay representative could you
expand on that
the confidential Clause what's that
about how does it work yeah I think your
representative for your question it
basically it'll cover these individuals
if they
are
talking to another peer in one of these
situations and there the peer explains
something to them that they're going to
be taking into confidentiality and not
required to report to the law
follow-up follow up so where in statute
or somewhere else does it actually
talk about that and and indicate that
they would then be covered by that if
this bill became law
I don't know that answer
[Music]
this is definitely more complicated than
I thought it was when I originally came
up with this amendment
so I'd like to send at least this part
of Senate Bill 207 to representative
Simon subcommittee
and Madam chair if I may whenever that
subcommittee is scheduled I'd be happy
to make a workers comp attorney better
answer any of your questions than John
or I are trying to to um hopefully lend
some clarity
I mean that's
I'm still still confused of whether we
need it and what kind of liability
issues we're dealing with but
we'll let the subcommittee dig into it
that's okay Madam chair I think my
subcommittee is becoming slowly experts
at work comp all of a sudden so
congratulations
it's always good to learn things
all right
um
uh no
okay that's uh that completes our
actions for this for today we have two
bills that we haven't finished that we
will pick up later on and the
subcommittees will be busy
and
the subcommittees will be busy they will
be scheduling the meetings and I I have
a report from representative shewitt and
from representative Goldie thank you
very much uh representative Gould Simon
Rhoda and leckis
oh one each so
and I just need it tonight as soon as
possible yes 108. yes thank you ma'am
I'll check you off you have it in I do
and uh feel free if it's two wording or
okay
goalie's got his in
by the end of the night
as soon as soon as you can
work and stuff there's work and stuff
it's been it's been a tough week for me
okay
[Music]
uh yes they came this way
representative Grote
Jackie
and you set your subcommittee up but
it's a